members take your seats
too
much
foreign
members take your seats
thank you
thanks
the house will come to water
the chair recognizes the member from
Auburn representative Osborne who moves
the house adjourned from the session of
February 14
2023. are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye pray for Paul's
name the eyes have it the house is
adjourned the house will attend to a
Prayer by guest chaplain member from
Exeter The Honorable Alexis Simpson
thank you
good morning
to Center us this morning I'm going to
share a piece from Howard Thurman's
meditations of the heart let us be in an
attitude of prayer and contemplation
how good it is to Center down to sit
quietly and see oneself pass by
the streets of our minds seethed with
endless traffic
our Spirits ReSound with clashings with
noisy silences while something deep
within hungers and thirsts for the still
moment and the resting lull
with full intensity we seek air the
quiet passes a fresh sense of order in
our living
a direction a strong sure purpose that
will structure our confusion and bring
meaning in our chaos
we look at ourselves in this waiting
moment the kinds of people we are
the questions persist
what are we doing with our lives what
are the motives that order our days
what is the end of our doings
where are we trying to go
where do we put the emphasis and where
are our values focused
for what end do we make sacrifices where
is our treasure and what do we love most
in life
what do we hate most in life and to what
are we true
over and over the questions beat in upon
the waiting moment
as we listen loading up through all the
jangling Echoes of our turbulence
there is a sound of another kind
a deeper note which only the Stillness
of the heart makes clear
it moves directly to the core of our
being
our questions are answered our Spirits
refreshed and we move back into the
traffic of our daily round
with the Peace of the Eternal in our
step
how good it is to Center down
amen
the chair recognize the member from New
Market represent Charlie Lorenzo who
will lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance
foreign
recognizes sisters Josie and Lily Lyon
of Garfield who will now sing our
national anthem
oh say can you see
by the dawn's early light what's so
proud ly we
held at the twilight's last gleaming
whose broad stripes and bright stars
[Music]
but we watched we're so gallantly
streaming
[Music]
bye
spring
through the night
that our flag was still there oh say he
does that Star-Spangled
rain
by the land of the
books
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
house will attend a request for leaves
of absence
Mr Speaker the day illness
representative's foot Judy Mason Mills
Thomas Walsh the day important business
Representatives Buras Bill Boyd Buco
cambrells cascaden Cole Damon Ford Lloyd
Wayne McDonald McLean O'Hara Jeffrey
Smith the day illness in the family
representative Tellez
these leaves of absence shall be grand
unless otherwise ordered by the house
house will attend to the introduction of
guests Mr Speaker please welcome Caitlin
kazansky guest of Representative
treeleven Krishna sarayu Debbie and
vikas manjaputi and Johannes Santosh
Maynard khrujiputi husband daughter
daughter-in-law and Son of
Representative mangaputi David Jones and
Hanson Lou Jones guests of
Representatives Alicia and Tony lekkas
Brendan and Sean Hopper Anna and Sophia
Hamill Damon Hess and Lee ruddock family
of the former member from where the
honorable Gary Hopper guest of
Representative Cushman
Sarah and Peter Lyon parents of the
singers guest of the house members of
the Epping Senior Center guests of
Representative alone grips from the
Raymond Coalition for youth communities
for alcohol and drug-free youth
partnership for drug-free youth of
Laconia and Franklin partners of in
prevention guests of Representatives Tim
Cahill Pratt and Lily Walsh
representative elect Chuck grassy guest
of Representative Fitzpatrick there with
us in the gallery today
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
do you recognize the member from Weir
representative Cushman from Memorial
marks for former member of firmware The
Honorable Gary Hopper
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker
The Honorable Gary Hopper was born in
Medford Massachusetts on January 5th
1957 to parents Michael and Betty he
graduated from Nashoba High School in
Bolton Mass
Gary worked a career as a tool maker and
a machinist for about 30 years
his wife Brenda was a teacher and they
shared 43 years of marriage together
they raised two beautiful children Anna
and Sean
Gary was also a wonderful grandfather to
his five grandchildren and
great-granddaughter
Gary loved the Lord he was a member of
the Congregational Church of Goffstown
for over 30 years
a light unto others in every way he was
always willing to help people in their
time of need
he was a true servant of Christ
I enjoyed talking about God with Gary he
always explained aspects of God's nature
in simple terms that were so encouraging
and inspiring of deeper meditation
Gary was down to earth as a young man he
had dealt with vices as an older man he
didn't pretend to be anything other than
who he was
and he helped others with their vices
he had a certain relaxed demeanor that
made it easy to talk to him
he had a joy for life
that combined with a sense of humor
unrivaled
are two key traits that made Gary so
likable
Gary was a great mentor
and a great friend I jokingly called him
my adopted Grandpa and he said that that
was awesome because it was a compliment
and an insult at the same time
The Honorable Gary Hopper served our
state as a representative from 2008 to
2022.
that's seven terms during that time he
represented the towns of Goffstown wear
and Deering
issues of particular importance to Gary
were the right to life the right to bear
arms and stopping human trafficking
representative Hopper served as the
chair of Fish and Game
and on the Judiciary and criminal
justice committees in this chamber he
had many friends on both sides of the
aisle
in 2005 when the U.S Supreme Court ruled
that Suzette kilo's house could be taken
by eminent domain not for schools
hospitals or highways but for tax
reasons there was outrage
one of the justices lived in Ware at the
time and under Gary's leadership the
locals banded together to take the
Justice's house by imminent domain
the town needed a new hotel that would
bring tax revenue and that location was
perfect
news media from all over the world
covered the bid to take the Justice's
house in the end the bid was
unsuccessful but because of Gary's work
the world wouldn't soon forget what
happened
afterward 44 State legislatures
including New Hampshire's changed their
constitutions in various ways in an
effort to make sure that this never
happens to a private citizen ever again
Gary certainly left a mark
everybody knew him for whistling the
Jeopardy theme song
many remember his speech about
paratroopers
that was before my time here
I remember how at the Bedford Sportsplex
he would always give me his granola part
granola bars because he was allergic to
nuts
he and The Honorable Susan dilemmis
would sing the national anthem together
Along with whoever was performing it and
it always made me smile
he often would ask to carpool with me
because we would get out late and his
eyes weren't so great
driving at night was difficult for him I
obliged but I never told him that my
eyes aren't so great either
one time I saw Gary's wife Brenda
driving in Goffstown and I pulled over
to say hi
Gary messaged me later that day and said
you're stalking my wife
I told them I saw her at Rite Aid and I
pulled over to say hi he said this is
why I told her she needs a gun
when Gary became sick I was worried he
texted me telling me that his cancer was
too intertwined with multiple organs and
surgery was not an option
I'm opting for Kamikaze nanoparticles he
said
I later understood this to mean that he
was having targeted cancer therapy
at one point our friend was told by
doctors that he only had two months to
live
by the grace of God his cancer markers
decreased and he was given more time to
be with his family
he felt a little better and he returned
to rock paper hand grenades temporarily
a show that he co-hosted since 2011 with
uh with a couple of co-hosts and most
recently Joshua Solomon
he joined some Republicans in where for
sign waving during campaign season and
made appearances at the polls
he cast his final vote in the first
election in 14 years that didn't feature
his name on the general ballot
several months later on February 12 2023
God finally ended Gary's suffering and
called him home to the kingdom of heaven
so today the New Hampshire House of
Representatives remembers The Honorable
Gary Hopper
we thank him for his years of service to
the Granite State we thank his wife
Brenda and the rest of his family
some of whom are here in the gallery
today for supporting him in his service
for all those years
and we ask God to bring comfort and
encouragement to all who knew and love
Gary and that his memory lives on
if you would now in remembrance of
Representative Hopper would you please
stand and join me in a moment of
whistling the Jeopardy theme song
[Music]
thank you
for a reason to memorize
all right
Mr Speaker I moved the memorial remarks
for The Honorable representative be
placed in the permanent journal without
objection
and also now attend
the house will now attend the consent
calendar
Mr Speaker from the committee on
criminal justice and Public Safety House
Bill 498 removed by Representatives
whole Cushman Spillane Dan McGuire
Bernardi papovichi Mueller Heinz Prout
con twist and Harrington
from the committee on Health Human
Services and elderly Affairs House Bill
598 removed by representative Sheehan
Diane Kelly Healey Nelson Hobson Baum
Alicia leckis Spillane Dan McGuire and
Gerhard
from the committee on state federal
relations and Veterans Affairs H.R 7
removed by Representatives petrigno
Siebert Baldwin news Newell Bouchard
Alexandra Murray Damon Morris and
Leclerc
from the committee on state federal
relations and Veterans Affairs H.R 16
removed by Representatives Gerhard Ellen
Reed wheeler Santa nastasso Heinz Oregon
Diane Kelly McCarter yokella and
papavichi Mueller foreign
calendar
you know it removes representative
Osborne moves at the consent calendar
with the relevant amendments printed in
today's house record be adopted are you
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
Uncle Paul's nay the ice Albert and the
consent calendar is adopted under house
rules and the committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety HP 46fn is
referred to the committee on finance the
committee on Health and Human Services
and elderly Affairs HB 397 is referred
to the committee on criminal justice and
Public Safety and from the committee on
state and federal relations and Veterans
Affairs HP 269 is referred to the
committee on finance
chair recognize the representative not
of her emotion thank you Mr Speaker I'd
like to make a motion to move House Bill
20 to the first order of business today
and I'd like to speak to my motion
you may speak your motion uh the family
of our late speaker dick kinch is in the
gallery today and since this bill
pertains to him it would be nice if they
can watch the proceedings in person
thank you
the question is on a motion to special
order all those in favor say aye
proposed nay the eyes have it
by the necessary two-thirds
three-fifths
okay
Committee on Public Works and highways
to which was referred House Bill 20 in
act naming a bridge in the town of
Merrimack for The Honorable Richard Dick
hinch considered the same report the
same with the recommendation of Bill
ought to pass it's in a bill bill Boyd
for the committee
chair recognizing representative
McConkey
good morning thank you Mr Speaker
having a chance to honor one of our own
or served in this body is unique in my
honor to stand before you
and his family this morning
my Fondest Memories of the Richard or as
we knew him dick hinge was no matter
what time of day when I ran into him was
his infectious smile he extended his
hand out to shake your hand and the
first thing before I could say anything
it was he would ask how I was doing on
that given day
we were very fortunate to have uh dick
hinge in our in our presence and it's an
honor again to be here uh form Public
Works and highways to name a bill in his
honor
um I would like to read a prepared
items for the family I know you all have
them before you this bill names the
Bedford Road Bridge which crosses the
babusik brook in Merrimack after our
former house Speaker dick hinge a proud
graduate of Marblehead High School in
Salem State University in an even
prouder veteran of the United States
Navy
dick was a man who dedicated his life to
service to others in the communities of
Merrimack
his numerous charity of charitable
events include the Nashua soup kitchen
children of Fallen Patriots the Liberty
house his Civic work in Merrimack
included stints with the Merrimack
Chamber of Commerce rotary and Lions
Club
he remained active to the Merrimack
American Legion and Veteran of foreign
war posts most importantly his admirable
commitment to governing our town is
particularly noteworthy budget committee
Solid Waste Library
development marking Zoning Board of
adjustment
chair of our former development
marketing Zoning Board of adjustment I
apologize in six terms as a member of
the New Hampshire General Court
culminating in the election of speaker
of the New Hampshire House of
Representatives highlights his
commitment to serving others and getting
the best outcome possible
Dick's final words as Speaker of the New
Hampshire House of Representatives
personifies the essence of his true
character and of his Humanity
we have many different ideas but we want
to do what we believe is right and there
is nothing political and partisan about
that
the naming of the Bedford Road Bridge in
honor of Richard Dick hinge will serve
as his legacy to the town of Merrimack a
veteran reminder of his services to
Merrimack built bridges for the
community and for the granite state
I ask that you support the public works
and highways
by pressing
the green button
the motion before us is the ought to
pass motion on House Bill 20.
representative McConkey requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded
members take your seats
if you haven't turned your station on
turn them on
thank you
the motion before motion before I see on
a pass motion and House Bill 20 this is
a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button warning stations are open
for 30 seconds
foreign
was present at an opportunity to vote
Council appendicator vote
356 voting a or voting a
before we go on to the regular calendar
I'd just like to take a moment of
personal privilege myself first of all I
want to recognize
Pat
his wife and Kelly his daughter in the
gallery up above
Pat and Kelly
foreign
calendar
majority of the committee on Commerce
and consumer affairs to which was
referred House Bill 459 FN act relative
to transactions exempt from the
regulation of business practices for
Consumer Protection have been considered
the same
report the same with the following
resolution that it is inexpeding to
legislate Senator Keith Hammond for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation of Bill ought to pass Mr
Merle Gibbs for the minority of the
committee
are you ready for the question
follow us in favor say aye
principal's name
you guys have it and the committee
report is adopted
foreign
House Bill 531 FN and relative to the
taxation of tobacco and nicotine
products having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate instead of Jane volio for
the committee
foreign
recognizes representative Stringham
to speak against the committee report
good morning and thank you Mr Speaker
I Rise to ask this body to vote no on
the committee recommendation of itl and
instead pass the amendment in your seat
pocket
uh House Bill 531 deals with tobacco and
nicotine taxes which represent about 10
percent of our annual funds raised in
the granite state
House Bill 531
was written to make sure that our rates
are competitive in the region
by adjusting rates
to even eight eight percent below other
states all other states in the region we
would raise about 20 million dollars uh
would raise some tax rates and it would
lower at least one other
uh House Bill 531 was also written in
part to get engage those in the front
line in the trenches in New Hampshire we
have 10 000 or more of them they are
state employees
the inspiration for me came from reading
an article in the New York Times in
November 2022 which dealt with online
Sports gambling passed by the
legislature in 2018 to 2020.
let me quote from the article it says
today 31 States permit Sports gambling
online the gambling industry pressed
states to set tax rates low on sports
betting warning that if States pushed
the rates too high sports fans would
turn to the black market to place bets
on unregulated sites
still quoting those warnings were
misplaced some States including New York
and New Hampshire ignored the industry's
advice and instead installed the highest
rates on betting they have seen bets
placed at a higher rate per capita than
the low rate states
well the New York Times didn't get it
completely right in New Hampshire the
Lottery Commission formed a joint
venture with an online sports betting
company
Ways and Means didn't create a low tax
we followed the employee's lead and
formed a partnership which yields a take
of over 50 percent of the amount bet uh
portion for uh payouts the monies we've
raised have helped set offset other tax
rates changes in the state
another example of a syntax where the
effective tax is largely set by
employees with our overtight is alcohol
the effective tax rate for hard liquor
like a bottle of Tito's is set by the
state-run liquor store through the price
over the amount they pay they charge the
Liquor Commission makes hundreds of
these decisions every day without the
legislature micromanaging them and
setting an exact amount above the cost
that they can charge
setting a proper method for taxation
Taxation and tax rate isn't easy and the
importance of the revenue largely from
cigarette tax is critical unlike other
tax part of the role of syntax is it is
discourage use of the item the American
Heart Association and the American
Cancer Society have called for us to
raise cigarette taxes by at least one
dollar per pack
these offsetting public health and state
revenue concerns are challenging for
groups like Ways and Means
still I recognize there were concerns
that some of the rates just by changing
by eight percent down to eight percent
below may represent a burden which is uh
in particular The Vaping tax which is
eight percent in the state of New
Hampshire and all of our surrounding
states have have a rate no lower than 44
percent
a difference like that is is reason
enough for Ways and Means to take a look
at it to see if we're getting it right
uh but the bill uh even after the
amendment still also includes engagement
about the use of tobacco funds including
the very important tobacco settlement
funds uh there are other opportunities
in what we do for example in North
Carolina they have a program called
Golden Leaf the Golden Leaf fund is
supplied over 55 million in higher
education grants in combination with
their legislature
so the information provided by the
report that would be an output of the
amendment would enable discussions with
ways and means to see if the portion of
the funds could be better and better
aligned
so this is uh this is a two committee
bill at this point which would go to
Ways and Means uh should the amendment
uh uh pass
uh without House Bill 531 in any form
Ways and Means will have no bills
related to tax to tobacco and nicotine
aside from the premium cigar bill they
have to serve as a vehicle for better
policy so therefore I ask you uh to
please vote no on the motion to itl so
that the motion uh the amendment can be
voted on which would just create a
report and allow Ways and Means to chime
in on nicotine and tobacco policy
thank you
chair recognize the representative hunt
speak before the community report
thank you Mr Speaker uh the Commerce
Committee is a policy committee and we
were looking at as a policy not at the
actual tax rates the policy being that
we were going to set in statute that we
would be requiring uh monitoring of
other states did not seem appropriate
for legislation
see that that is something that the Ways
and Means Committee has done
historically over the years they don't
need a bill to do it they can do it when
they set the tax rates when we come up
with the budget review so the Commerce
Committee almost uh overwhelmingly voted
to make this bill in expedient
representative San Andreas
that's officially seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded
are you ready for the question on the
motion before us in expedient to
legislate and house bill 531.
all those in favor say aye
no suppose nay
the eyes have it and committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on Commerce
and consumer affairs to which is
deferred House Bill 639 FNA act relative
to legalization and regulation of
cannabis and making Appropriations
therefore considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass for the amendment of John Hunt for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate
Senator Lily Waltz for the minority of
the committee the amendment is zero five
four three h printed in house Record 12
Pages 57 through 72. are you ready for
the question on the amendment all those
in favor say aye
well suppose nay
the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted
the motion before us now is ought to
pass as amended the majority report
chair recognizes representative Lilly
Walsh
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise today to speak out against the
passage of house bill 639.
this bill will create an addiction for
profit industry in our beautiful state
this bill does not contribute to the
common good it puts profits ahead of
public health and safety
it will create bigger government putting
an added burden on our taxpayers the
health safety and economic harms will
far outweigh the perceived social
benefits the costs of legalization of
cannabis will fire away any profits due
to increased Health Care obligations due
to addiction and increased law
enforcement due to collisions fatalities
and ambulance calls
the commercialization model is
collapsing every state that has
legalized cannabis has an exploding
Black Market
indeed the black Market's price will
always be lower than New Hampshire's
legalization of cannabis should not be a
political issue it's a public health and
safety issue
virtually every medical and Psychiatric
association in New Hampshire strongly
opposes legalization and
commercialization
the National Academy of Sciences States
the opioid crisis is worsening where
cannabis is legal
our Senator Gene Shaheen stated I don't
support legalizing marijuana we're in
the middle of an opioid epidemic and the
research that I've seen suggests that it
is a way that more people get into drugs
the Veterans Administration is on record
stating there is no evidence that
cannabis is an effective treatment for
PTSD
New Hampshire has no limit for a
cannabis intoxication and therefore
operators are not charged with DUI by
cannabis in regards to fatal crashes
maybe that's why the Billboard's
advertising for Amazon drivers in New
Hampshire state that they do not test
for cannabis
voting for this bill will usher in
intoxicated truck drivers bus drivers
tractor trailer drivers and Beyond
don't be fooled by the addiction for
profit industry that claim tax revenue
will solve all our budget problems
my colleagues I implore you do not vote
for this bill it will change our state
in unimaginable ways none of which
promote the common good
so Mr Speaker I ask to you for you to
join me and vote no on House Bill 639
and press the red button
Mr Speaker I ask for a division vote
as a member yield the questions
no I do not remember does not yield
chair recognizes representative bone
thank you Mr Speaker
I Rise also in opposition to the bill
marijuana is another gateway drug like
alcohol
talk to many addicts they say they
started either with alcohol or marijuana
then moved other drugs they needed to
get higher
I see there are two reasons people drink
alcohol either they like the taste and
I'll I'm with that or they need to drink
to cope with their life other than
medical marijuana but more on that later
the only reason to smoke or eat cannabis
is to get high
to cope with your life
and if Mana one it doesn't work it can
always move up the cocaine when we will
start pushing that
some years ago Harvard Medical came out
with a study showing that marijuana
causes brain damage in people under 21.
so let's make it easier for children to
get it
I was in high school in the military in
the 60s for those that remember or heard
of that period it was filled with
marijuana and Other Drugs
hippies flower children Woodstock
Etc
house will be in order
my high was going to parties and
watching people make complete fools of
themselves or Worse luckily we didn't
have smartphones and small social media
then
I never smoked Mal marijuana or took
those other drugs they were all readily
available
but a lot of us were too smart to follow
in that crowd and for the record I did
not live a sheltered life I was
completely much on my own since I was
15. I disowned my father and completely
left home when I was 17. and for those
that even today makes excuses for
themselves because of their life I say
you make your own life
let's say you get stopped while driving
and it looks like a DUI for alcohol it
can be proven breath or alcohol it
cannot be determined for marijuana it
will be subjective
the police they will be in your blood
for maybe two weeks
where marijuana the police officer will
subjectively prove you under the
influence may even say he or she may
even say they smelled marijuana
just like any profession there are bad
cops bad lawyers bad State reps
etc etc
and with legalizing it you will have
more marijuana Duo DUIs as new people
will now use it and at my age we'll have
a problem walking a straight line anyway
maybe the marijuana Lobby would spend
their money working on a non-subjective
way of determining if someone is under
the influence
and interesting I don't know about the
surveys but I never had anyone asking me
if I want to legalize marijuana in a
survey and I've answered questions
debate and debates Etc and I was against
it I know of reps that ran on opposing
it
and it appears even in other states that
have legalized it legalize it it's
cheaper on the street
the black market will get worse
now 21 year olds can legally buy it and
then sell it to their underage friends
and at one time in my life I believe
that everything should be legal I
thought I should be able to go to a
drugstore and get medicine but it ailed
me
why should I go to the doctor
but then I grew up and found out there
are stupid people that will injure or
kill themselves putting a financial
burden on the rest of us and where is
the state getting an illegal Federal
substance to sell
will it be laced with fentanyl
and then will the state be responsible
now for medical marijuana
I testified on this many years ago here
in the house floor
if marijuana is great for some illnesses
then why doesn't big Pharma sell it
you can get prescription then and be a
whole lot cheaper
they sell and walk at every other drug
but then it makes one high again it will
obscure any pain
I remember when medical marijuana became
legal in California a lot of the shops
had signed stating the doctor is in and
for 25 dollars you can get a
prescription for marijuana
and by the way I've taken opioid for
pain broken red motorcycle accidents
etc etc and both most of those pills
ended up in the police boxes and even
had not filled prescriptions so don't
blame the doctors it is your
responsibility but for people in
constant pain let them have what they
want
and because every other state is doing
it remember what your brother told you
if everyone just jumps off the bridge
are you going to follow
also
also if legal will be reselling spelling
it in any room some years ago you could
luckily the perpetrator was arrested for
other crimes and went to prison
a year ago last Friday though from those
here then remember I ended up I ended
the governor's speech
on my cable show on Friday my co-host
reminded me of that the governor called
me that day jokingly said I know we
don't agree on everything
but I do know that I agree with him on
this and so it will be vetoed
and don't be intimidated by leadership
that is sponsoring this bill you work
for your constituents not your
leadership and your vote counts the same
as theirs and I vehemently asked that no
one called for a roll call let us vote
our conscience I will vote no I vote
what's good for the state and
constituents
and one last thing
a lot of us this past summer signed a
pledge for no new taxes isn't paying a
tax on something new a new tax
so guess ability get high sometimes
overrides that played for some of us and
also this is another case will you need
an ID
so vote no on your pledge and protect
our children thank you Mrs remember you
owe the questions no member does not
yield
here recognizes my representative
Burroughs
thank you Mr Speaker and good morning HB
639 represents good represent good
legislation that is the result of the
Goodwill and diligent work of both
political parties the representative
from Auburn stated that what you are
looking at here is the result of a
number of months of work by the an
entire Coalition of groups and Advocates
everything from the business side to the
consumer side the Civil Rights side to
the economic Liberty side as well as the
recovery community and the people
concerned about child safety the end
result is a bill that may well be the
most comprehensive plan that we have
seen for legislation of cannabis in New
Hampshire
the house Commerce Committee labored to
come up with a final version of the
amendment that would work for members of
both parties and for those who spent
months working with the Cannabis
Coalition under the revised Amendment
there will be a liquor and cannabis
commission with a second commissioner to
oversee the sale and regulation of
marijuana and related products in
community hearing the consensus what's
that we should have experienced
Insurance Commissioners overseeing the
new cannabis industry to jump start this
important new industry in New Hampshire
the house Commerce Committee
has been a model of bipartisan
cooperation this term we disagree we
debate and challenge one another there
is now a culture of mutual respect and
cooperation
the result has been what we've been able
to learn from each other find common
ground and craft new collaborative
Solutions the amend this amendment is
the outcome of this work we will we can
now join other New England states that
offer safe regulated and profit and
profitable cannabis industry to their
citizens this amendment allows us to do
it the reasonable way the responsible
way the Innovative way and the
bipartisan way
in committee hearings the consensus of
those who labored on this bill agreed
that why they may have not gotten
everything that they wanted from this
bill they got what they needed and that
is to paraphrase the 21st century
philosophers Mick Jagger and Keith
Richards
I am proud to present this amendment to
you on behalf of the hard-working
members of both parties who made it
possible and I hope you will support not
only this Innovative bill but to
recognize what we can achieve as a
legislature if we were able to work
together I would urge you to vote OTB by
pushing the the green button that bears
the beautiful green color of the
cannabis plant thank you there's a
number of the other questions
does a member yield the questions
remember yields
representative verville
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
representative for taking my question
um I'm in my fourth term here and I I
remember we decriminalized up to a half
an ounce of marijuana in the state of
New Hampshire so if the Doomsday sky is
falling type testimony we're hearing
about this bill
um was to actually occur wouldn't we
have already seen that in the
decriminalization of a half an ounce or
a less of marijuana in the state I'm
sorry I don't understand your question
but we see Doom coming
sorry so we decriminalized marijuana
half an ounce or less in the state right
so when we hear testimony that it's
going to increase addiction it's going
to increase Supply it's going to
increase black markets uh driving while
under the influence and all that if that
was correct if that was true wouldn't we
already have seen those effects from the
previous decriminalization of a half an
ounce
I don't think that we've seen those
kinds of negative effects from marijuana
in the past and I don't think we will
with the legalization of this Bill thank
you representative I agree 100 thank you
Mr Speaker
is remembering all the further questions
remember yields
to Marjorie Smith
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you to my
dear colleague for being willing to take
my question
I spent a lot of time reading a very
very long amendment that I understand
was not presented to the Commerce
Committee until the very last moment
by the distinguished chair of the
committee
I am puzzled about one central point and
I wonder if you can help me when the
Liquor Commission was created as an
Enterprise operation it was to free The
Liquor Commission from any unnecessary
oversight by the legislature and other
um uh
uh and other oversight responsibilities
and I am really curious about why given
how difficult the situation is you would
agree to give to the Liquor Commission
the responsibility for figuring out how
we're going to make a success out of
this effort thank you
thank you representative I appreciate
the question
um I think again this was a delicate
dance and negotiation there were those
on the committee who did not feel that
the Liquor Commission was the
appropriate vehicle to oversee this
there were there were some including
those on the Cannabis commission who
thought that it would be more
appropriate to have a separate
um I'm sorry The Liquor Commission to
oversee it they thought it would be more
appropriate to have a cannabis
commission oversee it and again this was
one of the um one of the the things that
we felt that we needed to compromise
because we felt it was more important to
get this bill passed and to have
cannabis legalized in the state
as a member yield to further questions
remember yields
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you for
taking my question the body just heard a
couple of comments from speakers before
you to the effect of this would create
dangerous bus drivers dangerous truck
drivers uh were you aware as I am as a
commercially Drive licensed driver
myself that in fact all of those
positions require a commercial driver's
license and that is done by the federal
DOT which requires a drug test including
marijuana test in order to get said
license and a yearly test by your
employer and if you fail it not only do
you lose your job you also lose that
license and any ability to hold a future
commercial job were you aware
I was not fully aware of all that but I
appreciate the clarification
do you recognize representative Dyer
thank you Mr Speaker that's
representative dry
fellow Republicans
fellow Representatives
I rise in opposition to House Bill 639
when Vermont was considering legalizing
recreational marijuana back in 2016. I
wrote an op-ed for the local paper and I
asked this hypothetical question
if marijuana is legalized before a legal
standard for impairment is established
wouldn't it be a shame if the state
could not convict someone especially in
the case of an Accident Injury or
fatality
because there was no standard of proof
the question didn't stay hypothetical
very long
in September 2018 Keith Cushman of
Lebanon
consumed marijuana got in his truck and
drove at high speed into the ledge's
long Interstate 91 in Norwich Vermont
he injured himself and he killed
Theodore Haley
his passenger
all Cushman received was a suspended
sentence
how come
it's easy to convict someone
who's driving intoxicated because a
legal limit exists .08 and there is a
way to test that number a blood test
that will stand up in court as evidence
it doesn't work that way with marijuana
there is no legal standard for
impairment
some police officers are trained as drug
recognition experts
to help make the more credible Witnesses
in court but not every officer is a Dre
in fact in cushman's case the Dre could
only partially evaluate him because of
his injuries
the state would have had trouble
proving a felony DUI against him because
Vermont did not have objective roadside
tests
for impairment for anything other than
alcohol
y's family called it insane that the
state pushed for legalizing marijuana
without such a test in place
it's more than that
voting to legalize a drug for
recreational use without giving police
the tools they need to arrest and
prosecute impaired drivers is
indefensible
the hypothetical is now real
Theodore Haley died
Keith Cushman served no jail term
it is a shame that the state could not
improve impairment because it lacked a
standard of proof
his life was worth more than that
Haley's father said
in conclusion Mr Speaker
let's not make the same mistake that
Vermont did
because of a standard of no there was no
standard of proof
Keith Cushman walked free even though
his actions caused Theodore Haley to pay
with his life
please vote no on House Bill 639 Mr
member yield the questions no remember
does not yield
chair recognized representative Tim
Cahill
thank you Mr Speaker
honored colleagues
distinguished guests
I rise today in total opposition of this
bill
I could stand up here right now
we talk about all the statistics from
all the other states that have legalized
marijuana and are selling in their
states and all the reasons that it is
wrong for New Hampshire
but instead
I'm going to remind you
of where you are
this is New Hampshire
we are the leaders
of our nation our constitution set the
standard
we have Mount Washington we have 18.75
miles of Coastland
we have the Connecticut Valley
for our most important resource is our
people
and this bill
puts our people in jeopardy
I rise today to keep a promise
I promise my constituents that I would
oppose marijuana legislation and they
overwhelmingly elected me in my town
I stand right now today
to represent the voices of everyone in
this state touched by the opioid and
pandemic and the deaths of their family
members that have occurred from it
I Rise for them
and to keep a promise
thank you Mr Speaker and I urge you to
vote no on this bill
recognize representative hun
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker I rise in support of this
bill
and the amendment
and the reason I do so is because
what the Commerce Committee attempted to
do was to try to
create a balanced bill that will address
the issues that we have heard over the
years in terms of the legalization of
marijuana
obviously we can't solve some of the
testing problems or some of the other
issues that may occur and I understand
why people may not want to vote for
marijuana
but the issue that we had in Commerce
was if we're going to do this how do we
ensure that our citizens are getting it
safely
and when we look at the safety issue the
Commerce Committee is also the liquor
Commission
committee
along with the Liquor Commission is
tobacco
many people don't know how much our
enforcers
are actually responsible for ensuring
that tobacco is not sold to anyone under
1821.
what I want to say is is that it made
sense to not reinvent the wheel and
create a new Commission
that had an Advisory board that was
political right in the public hearings
people were adding wanted to add more
people to this Commission
what Commerce did was is say we're going
to take a model that we are successful
with here in New Hampshire
and repeat it
and therefore we chose the Liquor
Commission to be the regulatory body
they have the hearings officers they
have
group two officers who are entitled to
go in and making sure that underage
people will not be able to buy this
product
we are requiring the licensees to be
heavily regulated in terms of uh that in
terms of the uh how who they sell to and
also what they sell it has to be tested
by a third-party group that will be
certified by the state
so yes it is true that this bill was
modeled after Liquor Commission and some
and question about the modernization
well in the key element of the
modernization was that the legislature
should not be telling every little
Nuance that the Liquor Commission as
public hearings process and if you read
this bill you'll never see more rule
making than you ever see in any other
statute
the commission is
capable of doing this and more
importantly they're capable of doing it
safely and ensuring that we take care of
New Hampshire's citizen number one
priority which is not to allow marijuana
in the hands of younger age people
so I urge you to please support this
Bill thank you
a division has been requested members
take their seats
the Rope a rope
representative Murray is President roll
calls that's officially seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded this
will be a division vote
members will be in their seats
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended the majority report on House
Bill 639 this state division vote
chair recognizes representative Terry
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that the Commerce Committee
heard testimony opposing this bill
from representatives of two of our
state's most important constituencies
namely the head of the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police
who detailed the already numerous and
growing threats to Public Safety
connected to the use of cannabis
and a brave young woman and student at
Raymond High School
who described the already rampant
use of cannabis by those among our
state's School population
and if I know that according to the
testimony of the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police all
states that accompanied Colorado on the
path of legalization have now emerged as
the states with the highest percentage
of Youth users well above the national
average
and that so in Colorado for teens
marijuana is the most common drug found
in toxicology of those who die by
Suicide
and that quote there is no
representative is a parliamentary
inquiry not a speech
if I know if I know and if I know there
is no state that legalized the use of
possession of cannabis that has been
able to pay for it and if I know that in
every state where the possession and use
of cannabis was legalized the illicit
growing sale and distribution of
cannabis has proliferated and if I know
that this body has been entrusted with
the sacred Duty
and obligation to provide protection for
all of our citizens but particularly and
especially the most vulnerable of us
again and again if I know namely
our children who look to US
Representative this again this is a
parliamentary inquiry not a speech it's
usually about 15 seconds
if I know
all of the things that I know and that I
cannot say
regrettably
Mr Speaker would I not vote no on the
motion of OTP on HB 639 FNA so that
another motion may be made
thank you
chair recognizer representative hunt for
parliamentary inquiry
Mr Speaker
if I know that you have all made up your
minds
and if I know
that good things happen when it's the
third time
and if I know I want to make sure that
New Hampshire citizens don't have to go
out of state to practice Live Free or
Die will I now vote Yes on the pending
version
also be in order
the motion before us is the majority
report of Water Pass has amended on
House Bill 639 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you'll press
the red button boarding stations are
open for 30 seconds
I can't see representative thank you
representative
thank you
for our members president had an
opportunity to vote I also attend to the
state of the vote
to wondering 34 boarding a 127 voting
May a committee report is adopted
none of Richard's declared a conflict
and did not participate this bill is
being sent to Ways and Means
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety to which was referred Hospital
504 FN act relative house will be in
order
and act relative to your Adult Parole
Board and making an appropriation
therefore having considered the same
report the same the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass Senator Karen
Reid for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
Paul's nay
the eyes have it
and the committee report is adopted and
the bill is going to finance
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 272 FN enact
increasing Charter Public School for
pupil funding have been considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with Amendment Senator
Glenn cordelli for the committee the
amendment is zero two two three-h
printed in house Record 12 pages 41. are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
I suppose nay the eyes have it amendment
is adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment are you
ready for the question
a division has been requested members
will take their seats
is them
the motion before us is not a password
Amendment
on House Bill 272 FN
this is a division vote
chair recognized representative Miler
for a parliamentary inquiry
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that the per per pupil grants
for public charter schools has not been
increased in five years
and if I know that the original Grant
proposal was reduced from fifteen
hundred dollars to a thousand dollars
if I know that the education committee
looked at the need to increase funding
for public charter schools as well as
public schools and House Bill 539 and
concluded that there was a need for both
and finally if I know that nine charter
schools have closed due to fiscal
constraints
if I understand these issues Mr Speaker
would I now press the green button and
support the strong bipartisan
affirmative vote on HB 272 thank you Mr
Speaker
the motion before us is ought to pass
with Amendment on House Bill 272 FN
this is a division vote here in favor
you'll press a green button if you
oppose you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
foreign
had an opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
348 voting a 11 voting nay I don't think
I have to vote on this one
committee report is adopted and it's on
its way to finance
the committee on education to which it
was referred
I'll spell 492 FN enact requiring
Department of Education to provide the
House and Senate standing committees
responsible for Education with copies of
the laws rules relative to education
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment in the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment Senator Glenn
cordelli for the committee
the amendment is zero one five one H
sprinted in house Record 12 page 54. you
ready for the question on the amendment
all those in favor say aye
no proposed a
your eyes have it and reminisce adopted
motion before us now is ought to pass
with Amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
Mr proposed a the eyes have it and the
committee report is adopted and it's on
its way to finance
thank you
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 529 FNA local act
relative to additional Aid grants for
schools based on free and reduced price
meals and fiscal capabacity disparity
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and
recommendation of the bill at a password
amendment in a brick lad for the
committee the amendment is
0544h printed in house Record 12 Pages
55-56 ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
Mr post nay your eyes have it the
amendment is adopted we have a request
for a roll call by representative son
and natasto got sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted and it's on its way to
finance
majority of the committee on Executive
Department's Administration to which was
referred House Bill 250 FN act relative
to the accidental death benefit payable
to a group 2 member and considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
then of Matthew Simon for the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
grieve in the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate Senator Chris
Drew for the minority of the committee
has requested a parliamentary inquiry
or I roll a call and is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
thank you
foreign
is on a pass on House Bill 250.
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative senator
natasto for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill
downshot downshifts cost the towns in
violation of article 28a of the New
Hampshire Constitution
and if I know that group two members
already receive a hundred thousand
dollars from the general fund uh their
families receive that money
um for death benefit and already get 50
earnable compensation
and if I know that money doesn't undo a
death and this is just feel good
legislation then would I press the red
button belonging this motion so another
motion can be made thank you
chair recognizes represent O'Brien for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know currently a member who is
retired and if they choose the right
option can pick the option to get a
hundred percent for the surviving spouse
and if I also currently know that and I
thank my higher power
that there are only six people in the
State
firefighters and police officers who
have been killed in the line of duty
that are now receiving this particular
benefit and finally
if I know that the intention of this to
go to 100 isn't really somebody on the
high end but I'm talking about the
firefighter or the police officer just
starting their career
the ones that are used in the
the cardboard box of TV came in as a
coffee table with the drape on it like I
did
those are the people that are going to
need this protection if they should ever
get called upon to make the Supreme
sacrifice then when I press the green
button thank you
the motion before is the majority
committee report of ought to pass on
House Bill 250. this is a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press a green
button if your opposal press the red
button the voting stations are open for
30 seconds
foreign
was President an opportunity to vote
also attend the state of the vote
260 voting a 103 voting a committee
reporters adopted and this is on its way
to finance
majority of the committee on Executive
Department's Administration to which was
referred House Bill 436 FM local act
relative to group 2 retirement under
transition Provisions in the retirement
system considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment the
recommendation has been a lot of
password Amendment Senator Matthew Simon
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
father and resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate Senator Matthew
son and Natasha for the minority of the
committee
the amendment is zero four eight three h
inted in house Record 12 pages
47-53 are you ready for question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
don't suppose nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted the chair
recognizes representative true
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker in the interest of time I've
combined three or four of my speeches
into just one speech that speaks against
the committee report of otpa on this
bill
Mr Speaker I believe that this bill
replaces the pension reforms of 2011.
and Mr Speaker I know that the projected
cost of this bill was stated to be
250 million dollars
I also know that the small group of
people this bill is written for consists
of only 1700
and 31 people
and I know that this class of 100
1731 represents one ten thousandth
of one percent
of the New Hampshire population
Mr Speaker I know that the New Hampshire
Constitution Article 10
states that government
being instituted for the common good
common benefit
protection and security of the whole
community
and not for the private interest or
emolument of any one-man
family or class of men
in closing
please allow me to quote from one of our
country's greatest
Acid Rock
garage Punk singers
of all time
Taylor Swift
it was the best of times
it was the worst of crimes
Taylor Swift felt like she was in a
speeding getaway car
I feel like I'm in a speeding Runaway
Train
and there's nothing I am able to do I'm
not able to do anything about it
I believe that a bill written for such
an infinitesimal percent of our
population
is not instituted for the common good
nor is it instituted for the whole
community
and thus I feel this bill goes against
the New Hampshire Constitution
I asked for a roll call vote Mr speaker
thank you
chair recognizes representative Simon
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise today in support of hb3 436 it's
a complicated Bill and so I will do my
best to convey to the general court some
of its intricacies what I would like to
start with is just explaining kind of
the background history of how this
situation came to be back in the early
2000s pension systems across the country
started running into problems because
they weren't funded appropriately
legislation that had been passed in all
of those States left us uh in a
situation where we could not meet all of
the obligations of the retirement system
over the course of the life of the
people who were in them so in 2011 New
Hampshire not being an exception to that
rule I got a group of legislators
together to try to address the issue and
on the whole I think that they did a
fantastic job
um we were possibly running into
insolvency they made a lot of decisions
that really shored things up
um
as um sorry
um so three things contributed to uh the
shortfall first uh we weren't funding
the program appropriately secondly at
the same time the federal government
released uh new mortality tables that
said that people were living longer and
since people were living longer their
calculations needed to go out further
which meant that the funds that we had
were we thought were going to be enough
work could be enough because it was
going to be spread out over a long
period of time the third was if we all
remember correctly after 2008 there was
a huge downturn in the stock market
meaning the value of our savings to go
towards the pension program was now
worth less than it had been previously
so those three things contributed to
what we now have as the unfunded
liability of of the New Hampshire
retirement system so in order to address
that one of the things that we did back
in 2011 as we changed the calculation of
benefits for people in the New Hampshire
retirement system it used to be your
best three years average times the years
that you were employed times a 2.5
multiplier the new plan changed to your
best five years and
the time that you have the number of
years you've been employed and the
multiplier changed down to get down to
two percent eventually
so what we ended up with is the decision
of we have to change the plan we have to
change the benefits so that we can
afford to make sure that people get
their benefits in the future
where are we where I depart from the
people who made the decisions in 2011 is
simply this when do you implement the
new benefits calculation
they decided to do it
um basically at the point investment
investment is when somebody who's in the
retirement system now is locked in they
definitely get a benefit in New
Hampshire even though it wasn't in
statute this puts it in statute we
always operated as if it was 10 years so
you had to work 10 years for New
Hampshire uh retirement system to group
two in order to receive a definite
benefit retirement benefit for the rest
of your life if you hadn't reached that
10-year Mark what we did in 2011 is we
changed the calculations for people who
had already been working for nine nine
and a half years but were not yet vested
every other state
just made the changes from that point
forward new hires forward and so they're
just making the change for new hires
forward we went and we said no if you're
not vested meaning you could have worked
one year you could work five years you
could have worked nine and a half years
you were going on to a transitionary
um benefit calculation plan that was not
the one that you agreed to when you
signed on so my my concern with this my
problem with this is simply this
those men and women who have dedicated
their services and criminal justice and
fire and in police
dedicated their time
and they dedicated their money they have
to pay into the system with the
understanding that they were going to
get a specific benefit for the time and
the money that they put in and unlike
other Retirement Systems other unlike
other pension systems New Hampshire
um New Hampshire's retirement system is
in statute it's encoded in law
it's not a general contract like you
typically have somewhere else if you
went to the law the law said you put in
your time you put in your money this is
what the state of New Hampshire will do
for you
and we went back and we retroactively
changed that law to affect people who
who joined and started their employment
with a different understanding
and I just think from a moral ethical
standpoint
that's not that's not the right way to
do things
um it has created a drop in morale among
our group two members
um it has dropped our morale and our
ability to hire new members we have
heard testimony that if we're willing to
pass this bill which essentially rolls
back year after year people from the
transitionary compensation system back
to the original one that they had when
they were hired it'll be a 10-year
process every year a new group will be
rolled in we will have the ability to
retain people for longer and because
their benefit package will go up their
incentivized to stay even longer still
they might stay two three four five more
years and when we're already short
staffed in those areas areas like
criminal criminal justice areas like
police areas like fire we can't really
afford to lose more people out of that
system it will boost morale again and it
will help us to um to retain workers in
that way as well so
um I would just urge The General Port so
press the green button and support the
majority opinion of Edna and pass HB 436
thank you
representative Sano Natasha was
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
foreign
okay
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of Auto pass is amended
on House Bill 436.
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative true for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill
would have us spend an average of about
a hundred and fifty thousand dollars per
person
for a very specific group of 1731 mostly
Municipal Municipal Employees
and if I know this specific group has a
superior pensions to the newer employees
in the same jobs
and if I know that this matter has
already been adjudicated by the New
Hampshire Supreme Court
but I now push the red button to defeat
the pending motion thank you Mr Speaker
is the representative Carol McGuire for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that we
have a massive problem with the
Recruitment and Retention among our
group two workers that is police fire
and Corrections
and if I know that we have her testimony
that a
significant cause of that trouble is the
decreased pension benefits in particular
the
benefits for those who were employed but
not vested in 2011.
and if I believe that the money we're
putting into this from the general fund
will relieve some of our Recruitment and
Retention problems would I not press the
green button
motion before us is the majority
committee report of Auto pass has
amended on House Bill 436.
this is going to be a this is going to
be a roll call vote here in family
you'll press a green button of the
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
Palmer was president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
282 voting yay 80 voting a committee
reports adopted and it's on its way to
finance
and representative Raymond declared a
conflict and it did not participate in
the vote
committee on executive departments and
administration to which it was referred
House Bill 571 FNA relative to the cost
of living adjustments for certain group
2 retirees the New Hampshire retirement
system this comes to be for us without
recommendation
uh representative goalie moves ought to
pass here I recognizes representative
Simon
thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
opposition to HB 571 uh the purpose of a
cola is essentially to allow people in
the retirement system to keep up with
um the difficulties of inflation
um and so from my perspective the reason
to give a cola is to help the people who
are in the most need who are suffering
the most under the weight of inflation
to get the help that they need to be
able to to pay their bills and I just
want to give you a few reasons why I
think 571 is an inadequate Bill to
accomplish that task outside of the New
Hampshire retirement system the the
closest comparative system is Social
Security and even in the minority
reports some
some comparison between the New
Hampshire retirement system and Social
Security was made stating that Social
Security people members get colas they
recently received a cola
um but I just want to make sure that the
body is informed of the difference
between Social Security and the New
Hampshire retirement system at least as
well as I can the New Hampshire
retirement system is a little bit of a
rabbit hole and the more you go down the
more complicated it gets however if I
were to take the first group of retirees
2013 that would benefit from this Cola
the average pension for firefighters
coming out of that group in 2013 was 57
231 that is a pension that they will
receive annually from now until they die
and then surviving spouse as well so
um so that would be their average
benefit
um it's the for these particular people
it's their three best years average to
get
um to to use as their multiplier for
Social Security they use your best 35
years and it is inflation that adjusted
to be fair does inflation adjusted but
there's a cap there's a Max that you can
contribute to in Social Security year
after year if you max out that table for
35 years and you retire right now the
maximum benefit that you can get
inflation adjusted through Social
Security is forty three thousand dollars
in change
so the average firefighter in 2013
that's looking for a cola is already
receiving fourteen thousand dollars more
than the maximum social security benefit
if you if you max out the table is going
to receive so it's comparing apples and
oranges the other thing I would say
about it is if you retires in group two
you can start receiving benefits at the
age of 52.
um
whereas everybody else if you want to
receive your full social security
benefit you have to wait until you're
67. so if you're receiving 57 000 a year
from the age of 52 to the age of 67
you're going to accrue 858
000 worth of retirement benefits before
anybody else is even able to start
collecting
that being said once you start
collecting your Social Security benefits
if you've maxed out the table if you're
getting the maximum benefit that you can
you'll be in your 90s before you hit
that 858 thousand dollar Mark so that
means because our average lifespan is
about 82
most firefighters from that eight from
that year will receive more in
retirement benefits before everyone else
starts collecting then everyone else
will receive it before they die
and so if we're looking to give a cola
to people who need it the most on a wide
scale I don't think that this bill hits
the mark but I'll argue one more thing
even if we're just dealing with group
two members this bill misses the mark
the bill gives a five percent Cola for
up to the first fifty thousand dollars
of benefit for a group two retiree
yes they've been retired for 10 to 20
years it gives a 10 Cola to people up to
fifty thousand dollars a year if they've
been retired for 20 years or more what
does that mean well if we take the
highest recipient of a pension from that
10-year group that would be a hundred
and thirty six thousand dollar a year
pension uh for a retired police chief
that retired police chief already
getting a hundred and thirty six
thousand dollar uh pension if he's been
retired for 10 years will get a twenty
five hundred dollar increase
if you have a thirty thousand dollar
pension in the same group you'll get a
fifteen hundred dollar increase year
over year so the person who's making a
hundred and ten thousand dollars more
is going to get a larger benefit out of
this bill than the person who's
receiving a hundred thousand dollars
less if we're trying to get help to the
people who need it most this bill fails
miserably so for those reasons I just
urge uh the members of the general court
to press the red button and find this
bill in expedient to legislate thank you
representative uh Senator Testo has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded
the question before us is the
I'm sorry I'm sorry I get ahead of
myself here uh the chair recognized
representative goalie
thank you Mr Speaker
honorable colleagues
group two members
currently pay
into the retirement system as well as
the employers
the one thing group two members do not
get
is social security
and you need to remember that
and if they do for some reason get
enough quotas enough quarters in Social
Security by working a side job
the windfall exemption act can take as
much as 90 percent of what they are
entitled to away
so they do not see the benefits of
Social Security even though they pay
into it
so what this bill would do is provide a
Cola a five percent on the first fifty
thousand on any group two member police
fire Corrections
proud of the New Hampshire retirement
system or beneficiary of that individual
those have been retired at least 10
years
but less than 20.
it would also it would provide a 10 Cola
on the first fifty thousand dollars for
those who have been retired more than 20
years 20 years or longer as of July 1st
as most of you know
the latest
Cola for Social Security was 8.7 this
year
and group two members
don't get that Social Security if they
do it's a very limited basis like I just
explained
we also had testimony
that since the Inception of the
retirement system in 1967 and up until
callers would be granted by the
legislature and funded by the general
fund
then in 1983 the legislature codified
the funding of the coals establishing a
special account
and in the rsas
stated that the special account shall be
used only to fund or partially fund
additional benefits for retired members
of the retirement system
so it has been
part of the system when it was
established
in the early 90s the legislation made
changes to the special account and
stipulated first to provide supplemental
allowances or coalesce pursuant to RSA
100a colon 41A before any other benefit
could be funded from the special account
then we go to 2012 and we hear about all
the changes made in the system
and the legislature got rid of the
special account and the funding source
for future colas
so I stand here before you today asking
that knowing that the legislature in the
past funded retiree coal is knowing that
retiree colas are necessary to help keep
up with the cost of inflation than what
I press the green button in both of us
thank you
foreign
other remember yield the questions
member does not yield
this is going to be a division vote
members take your seats
thank you
the motion before us is
Auto pass on House Bill 571 this will be
a division vote chair recognizes Carol
McGuire for a parliamentary inquiry
speaker if I know that this
this bill which creates a cost of living
increase only for group two is divisive
and if I also know that we granted a
cola two years ago to all of the lowest
paid retirees in the system from both
Group 1 and group two
and if I know that this would require 84
million from the general fund
would I not press the red button so that
a different motion can be made
I recognize represent over Bryant for a
parliamentary
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that the
state established a system of paying
calls to group two retirees since the
start of the New Hampshire retirement
system way back in 1967.
then in 1983 they codified the funding
with a special account until 2012 when
it was unfortunately eliminated
and if I further know since that time of
granting colas has been at the whim of
the legislature was several years
passing even though the federal
government has issued increases of
Social Security
a benefit group two members do not
receive by law
then if you believe as I do that is the
state's responsibility to its nhrs group
two members to provide them with colas
in their retirement and then please vote
with me and the majority of the board of
Eda committee members of ought to pass
on this bill for if you say that this is
not the right time to fund such an issue
then I must ask when it is will you
please press the green button
the motion before us is ought to pass in
House Bill 571 this is a division vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button of your opposed you'll press the
red button pointing stations will open
for 30 seconds
foreign
it
well members president of the
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the vote
192 voting a 167 voting a committee
report has adopted
to have to set clear conflict and
empress and did not vote and this is on
its way to finance
we're going to uh
do our lunch right now we got a couple
of announcements representative Rulli
remember stay in your seats got a couple
we've got a couple of announcements
again announcement about tomorrow
thank you Mr Speaker the uh Alec meeting
that was going to be across the street
has been rescheduled to the end of March
right now so no meeting tomorrow thank
you
thank you
everybody's wondering what's going to
happen tomorrow
as of this morning we've been watching
the natural National Weather Service uh
messaging uh not channel nine uh
and we are going to uh continue with our
session tomorrow we're going to do it at
10 o'clock
and uh we'll try and get everybody out
of here my we're moving pretty good
today so we'll try and get everybody out
of here like four o'clock tomorrow my
intention is to get out of here today
between five and six
so everybody has a chance to get home
before the bad weather hits uh but the
national weather service has this
under six inches from Laconia down
pretty much
and I know we're all partying Granite
Staters that six inches of snow doesn't
mean that much and in the lower part
below Concord it's actually two to four
so we will be meeting tomorrow at 10
o'clock
uh
we'll come back at one o'clock
difference
one of those
things
foreign
[Laughter]
okay
exactly
foreign
the majority of the committee on Health
and Human Services and elderly Affairs
to which was the house will be in order
to which was referred Health considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment the recommendation
Bill had a password Amendment
to Joe Shapiro for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee
have been considered the same being
unable to agree with the majority a
report with the following resolution
resolved that is in expedient to
legislate representative Eric can lay on
for the minority of the committee
the amendment is 01608 printed in-house
Record 12 page 43. are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say aye
do you guys have it and the amendment is
adopted the chair recognizes
representative Leon
opposition to House Bill 282 not because
I want to deny care to this population
but because Medicaid is not the solution
our Health Care system is in crisis one
that is long before covid and it was
long before the Affordable Care Act we
have a shortage of hospital beds because
of systemic problems and extending
Medicaid to pregnant immigrants and
their children will not solve the
capacity problems
it will change shift what is currently
charity care
to Medicaid care
when that happens
somebody needs to pay
for every person who's getting Medicaid
that's paid at a rate that's lower than
the hospitals can provide the cost to
private insurance goes up
that cost to private insurance goes up
premiums go up we shove our families
that are living paycheck to paycheck
into the Medicaid system because they
can no longer afford their own care
we're adding people to lifeboats and the
lifeboats just don't have that space
I love our new neighbors having
immigrants come to New Hampshire is
wonderful
we have families that want to come and
build communities build businesses build
restaurants and build friendships
many of these families are getting
employment getting health insurance from
their employer many others are buying it
from the health exchanges
we do have some that aren't able to
provide for their care
and I don't know about you but I'd
rather look to charity rather than to
expanding government programs
if you've looked around on sorry if you
looked around on Facebook how many
people are telling their story and how
many people are getting scammed because
we want to help each other people don't
know how to help
but if we can direct people that want to
help about how to support these these
endowments or even the direct pay that
take immigrants and other people who
cannot otherwise provide for their care
we will feel good and we will do good
I know in the legislature we usually
look to the government to solve problems
it's easy because we do government
programs so that's the way that we try
and help
but we often miss the people
who are aren't helped or who are
actually harmed when we expand these
programs
we need to realize that no matter how
compelling it is to try and Extend
Health Care to people all we're doing is
changing who pays and all we're doing is
sending that cost to other families that
are on the margin
we need to stop adding more people to
Medicaid the model is broken it's
costing us all please press the red
button so that another motion can be
made just remember yield the questions
no remember does not yield
chair recognize the representative
Shapiro
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise in support of the bipartisan
committee report of ought to pass as
amended on HB 282
HB 282 is a simple bill it will increase
health care access to a small group of
low-income New Hampshire residents
in 1996 President Clinton's welfare
reform act imposed a five-year waiting
period for immigrants to be eligible for
a variety of federal benefits
therefore many New Hampshire immigrants
today even if they qualify by income
must wait five years to be eligible for
Medicaid or for chip
in 2009 however the federal government
created an option
to states to eliminate that five-year
wait for children and for pregnant women
who are lawfully residing in the U.S but
not yet citizens
New Hampshire is the only state in the
Northeast and one of only 15 states in
the whole country that has not taken
that option
this bill of past will require New
Hampshire to amend the Medicaid State
plan to provide coverage for otherwise
eligible children and pregnant women
those considered lawfully residing
include those who have recently been
granted a green card
Asylum applicants those on temporary
protected status and victims of domestic
violence
it should be clear that this bill will
result in health care coverage for a
small number of lawfully residing New
Hampshire immigrants
it does not apply to undocumented
immigrants
the LBA estimates that in the first year
Health Care will be provided to
approximately 300 people at a cost of
just over two hundred thousand dollars a
year
access to prenatal care and regular
health care for children is an important
investment in public health and will
save money through prevention And Timely
diagnosis
lack of or delayed prenatal care is
associated with low birth weight and
multiple maternal and childhood medical
conditions
when enacted this spill will reduce
uncompensated care for health care
providers who are already stressed
this includes our federally qualified
Health Centers who serve thousands of
uninsured and small rural hospitals that
struggle to maintain labor and delivery
services
while there will be a cost for easing
Medicaid and Chip eligibility the
federal government will pick up much of
it eliminating The Five-Year wait for
immigrant children and pregnant women
will send a clear message that we
welcome and value newcomers to our state
who enrich our communities and add to
the workforce as employees and
entrepreneurs
eliminating The Five-Year wait for
immigrant children and pregnant women is
a wise financially Sound Investment in
New Hampshire families
the Catholic Archdiocese of Manchester
called it a pro-life bill
I urge you to vote Yes on the order pass
as amended motion by pushing the green
button so that we can take a small but
significant step towards increasing
access to health care for all New
Hampshire residents
thank you Mr member of yield the
questions
no I don't remember it does not yield
a division vote has been called members
take your seats
emotion before us is the majority
committee report of autopass has amended
on House Bill 282. this will be a
division vote
the chair recognizes representative
Cushman for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know
that adding the addition of cohorts to
the Medicaid pool continuing this
pattern will only increase the strain on
an already fragile Health Care system
and if I know that it doesn't address
the barriers preventing Market forces
that could reduce health care costs
legitimately
and if I also know that this bill will
increase health insurance premiums would
I now press the red button so that
another motion can be made
gee I recognizer representative Weber
for parliamentary inquiry
speaker
I know that having Medicaid
allows moms and kids access preventive
care and early care which prevents the
need for much more expensive Critical
Care down the road
and if I know that that critical care
costs fall on all of us one way or
another
and if I fervently want to support
all mothers and children in this state
when I press the green button to support
the ought to pass recommendation thank
you
the motion before us is the majority
committee report a lot of Paso has
amended and Hospital
282 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press a green button if
your opposer press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
foreign
can't push the button
what's up
Wellman was president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
hit the okay in the middle
186 voting yay 170 voting a committee
report is adopted and it's on its way to
finance
pretty young Health and Human Services
an elderly Affairs to which was deferred
House Bill
565 FNA relative to expanding Medicaid
to include certain postpartum health
care services this is without
recommendation
the amendment is is
representative Shapiro moves out of pass
and offers Amendment
0-304h printed in house Record 12 page
56. are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say aye
I suppose nay
the division has been called
members only in the chamber can vote
members will take their seats
members will take your seats this is a
division vote
the question is on the adoption of the
amendment
zero three o four h
this is on the amendment only
foreign
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
everything
all members president had an opportunity
to vote I also attend the state of the
vote
under an 82 voting yay 172 voting a the
amendment is adopted chair recognizes
president of Cushman
speak against the committee report
thank you Mr Speaker
this bill seeks to have our state join a
federal program that would give an extra
10 months of pregnancy Medicaid benefit
to postpartum women up from the two
months postpartum coverage they
currently have
supporters of the bill say this will
provide Health Care to women when they
are at an increased risk of
cardiovascular disease this is a good
thing however there is no income
eligibility requirement for this
extended taxpayer-funded health
insurance and after two months most
women return to the workforce
so they could be making six figures and
still be on Medicaid
the state of New Hampshire cannot tailor
this bill to fit our needs as a state
we cannot require an income eligibility
we cannot reduce the number of months
and the terms are completely dictated by
the federal government
not only that but in the health human
services and elderly Affairs committee
we have heard time and again how the
large pool of Medicaid patients is
straining our Hospital Systems adding
another cohort to that pool will only
further stretch health system resources
the idea that we solve all Health Care
access issues by creating more
categories of people eligible for
Medicaid is misguided
we've seen that more Medicaid equals
less bets in hospitals due to inadequate
reimbursement
the res this results in lower quality
care for all patients this is not good
health policy
additionally there has not been
convincing evidence brought forth that
this bill is even necessary or Justified
there are increased mental health and
cardiovascular risks for women in the
postpartum period yes however there are
also increased mental health and
cardiovascular risks for men and women
after surgery
people of all walks of life are at
increased risk for various health
conditions depending on their lifestyle
age diet careers and genetics the answer
to helping people is not scooping them
into a Medicaid Eligibility pool
that is no guarantee that they will
access Quality Health Care instead we
need to focus on fixing our broken
Health Care system and bringing more
affordable options to Consumers
continuing to increase the number of
Medicaid recipients is eventually going
to make the system insolvent
in fact Josiah Bartlett's Center for
politics today released an article and
was talking about how the Congressional
budget office made a recommendation that
the federal government starts to
decrease eligibility for Medicaid and
also shift more of the costs to the
states to prevent the program from
becoming insolvent and to deal with the
federal deficit
foreign
if the system becomes unsolvent at that
point
what will happen
will the government have to step in and
provide government health insurance for
everyone
I hope not
we've seen how that plays out in other
countries
but what I do know is that we see
Medicaid expansion bills like this every
year
and we hear how the payermix of
insurances is putting a strain on our
health care industry
how Medicaid doesn't pay enough and that
we need to prop up the system by
increasing premiums for private
insurance and maintaining protectionist
policies that keep out the competition
that could truly Drive costs down
it's a house of cards let's not add
another unnecessary unjustified program
that costs millions of dollars just
because the federal government is
offering a match especially when there's
no income eligibility requirement and we
have no authority over the structure of
the program thank you Mr Speaker
also be in order
chair recognized representative Shapiro
thank you Mr Speaker
I come before you today in support of HB
565 FN
the idea for this bill did not come out
of thin air
nor was it the brainchild of our
committee or The Honorable
representative who brought it to us
it is an option created by centers for
Medicare and Medicaid services to
address a very real and specific problem
the U.S has a significantly higher rate
of maternal mortality than other wealthy
and even not so wealthy countries around
the world
statistics from 2019 indicate that there
were 17.4 maternal deaths per 100 000
live births in the U.S compared to
4.5 in the Czech Republic and 1.1 in
Poland
just to name a few examples
there is a growing recognition that
postpartum period extends far beyond 60
days
this bill will extend Medicaid maternity
but care benefits for the current from
the current 60 days to a full year
pursuant to the state option under the
American Rescue plan
thus far 35 states have or are planning
to extend postpartum coverage including
all the states in the Northeast
currently many women lose coverage at a
critical time leading to undiagnosed and
untreated conditions such as
cardiovascular disease hypertension
depression and substance use disorders
in fact the 2022 New Hampshire report on
maternal mortality reveals that
approximately 40 percent of maternal
deaths in the previous two years here in
New Hampshire had occurred between 43
days and one year after childbirth
approximately 25 percent of New
Hampshire's new mothers are recipients
of Medicaid
only 25 percent because Medicaid is a
Health Care Program for low-income
people and there is an eligible income
eligibility to get on Medicaid
over 10 percent of new moms report
symptoms of depression others struggle
with substance use disorders treating
these conditions through the first year
will not only result in improved
maternal health
it will enhance the ability of mothers
to parent their newly born it will
improve the well-being of our youngest
Granite Staters and offer our children
the future that they truly deserve
this is a common sense fiscally
responsible remedy for a high rate
of preventable pregnancy-related
mortality and morbidity
contrary to some who believe Medicaid
recipients will intentionally become
pregnant just to maintain their coverage
the benefit would actually increase
options for Family Planning and reduce
unintended future pregnancies
once again this is a bill that the
Archdiocese the Roman Catholic
Archdiocese of Manchester called a
pro-life bill
expanding postpartum Health Care
coverage is a wise investment in the
health and well-being of New Hampshire
families I urge you to vote ought to
pass as amended on HB 565 by pressing
the green button and I would ask for the
vision vote Mr Speaker
representative Serenity has requested a
roll call voters that's sufficiently
seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
well the motion before us is auto pass
as amended on House Bill 565 FNA
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative Leon for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill takes us one
small step closer to Medicaid for all
and if I know that any discussion of
expanding Medicaid coverage or
eligibility should start with an
understanding that the current spending
levels are unsustainable
and if I know that increasing those
coverage just at accelerates the
inevitable collapse would I then press
the red button so that another motion
can be made
chair recognized representative Weber
for parliamentary inquiry
speaker
I know
he coverage for moms and kids for a
period of a year postpartum
will reduce costs by enabling them to
get preventive care and early Care at
lower costs outside of hospitals before
the problems become critical and must be
addressed at much higher costs to every
one of us
and if I fervently believe in supporting
the Health and Welfare of all New
Hampshire children's and Ma children and
moms would I now press the green button
and pass this Bill thank you
motion before us is the auto passes
amended motion on House Bill 565 FNA
this is a roll call vote you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you
opposed you'll press the red button
boarding stations are open for 30
seconds
foreign
give it
well Memphis president had an
opportunity to vote also attended the
state of the vote
184 voting yay 179 voting a committee
report is adopted and it's on its way to
finance
thank you
committee on health and animal services
and elbow Affairs to which was deferred
House Bill 574 FNA re-establishing the
special supplement and nutrition program
for women infants and children Farmers
Market nutrition program
representative Weber moves ought to pass
and offers Amendment zero two nine four
h
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
the supposed nay
uh division has been called members take
your seats
the motion before us is the amendment
0294h printed in-house Record 12 page 56
this is a division vote on the amendment
only here in favor you'll press the
green button if you opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
immaculaire
representative Italian
representative
well members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the vote
283 voting a Ada the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass as amended here
recognizing representative coal fault
speak again
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise in opposition to house bill 574.
which would reinstate a failed program
that was discontinued in the state of
New Hampshire in 2011.
due to low participation
if you understand a little bit about the
Farmers Market nutrition program
you can quickly come to understand
exactly why there was low participation
this bill although well-intentioned
solves a non-existent problem
with a complex top-down solution
the Farmers Market nutrition program
as implemented under this bill would
provide a one-time benefit of thirty
dollars
to participants in the women infants and
children program also known as WIC
the objective ostensibly is to provide
access to fresh fruits and vegetables
for participants in that program
however participants in that program
already have access to fresh fruits and
vegetables virtually every supermarket
in this state
certainly all of the major chains
except WIC is a form of payment
and they sell fresh fruits and
vegetables
so there's actually not a problem being
solved here
it would however require that in order
to make use of that thirty dollar
benefit participants would have to seek
out and find and and get to a farmers
market or Farm Stand that is
participating in the program right now
if we look to our South where
Massachusetts has implemented this they
have about 100 108 I think if my memory
serves me correctly participating
vendors who who offer this
this benefit
they also have five times the population
that New Hampshire has so if you use
that as a proxy for the math you can say
that maybe 20 25 vendors are likely to
be authorized in New Hampshire if we're
really generous maybe 40 or 50. so to
make use of your one-time benefit of
thirty dollars you need to figure out
where those vendors are and get to a
farmer's market
there's also a significant burden for
the vendors themselves so there's an
application process you have to provide
a history of your sales that needs to
tie to your business tax returns you
have to provide photos photo IDs and
copies of social security cards for all
owners operators partners and board
members for the organization's selling
their produce
need to train your employees part-time
full-time or even volunteers need to be
trained in how to accept the WIC payment
for produce
and they need to be trained within 30
days of starting unemployment and then
they need to be retrained at least once
a year
you'll also have to implement an
electronic Payment Systems so that you
can receive the the WIC payment vouchers
or you need to
um
alternately apply to to use paper
vouchers instead
so you can quickly come to see how
this is one of those programs that's
very well intentioned
but as a top-down program that that
imposes complexity on the people using
it both on the sell side and the buy
side
it simply doesn't make sense that's why
this program had low participation in
the past
so a common definition of insanity is
doing the same thing over and over again
and expecting a different result
this program was discontinued in 2011
for very good reasons
as legislators we need to use scarce
taxpayer resources wisely let's apply
them to programs that are efficient and
effective not complex top-down programs
like one that has already proven to be
ineffective I ask my colleagues to
please join me in pressing the red
button to vote no on the otpa
recommendation so that an alternate
motion may be brought thank you Mr
Speaker
which I recognizer representative Weber
equal to come here
thank you Mr Speaker
as one of us in the house of 2011 I
remember that that was a time of
sparkly declining revenues and we did
away with many many many programs that
were effective and that were used and
that we needed
and we're only just now getting back to
reinstating some of them and this is one
the expenditure of the three hundred
thousand dollars will free up over a
hundred and ten thousand dollars federal
funds so we're leveraging the dollars
the benefit goes to women and children
on the WIC program
and yes they do have access to some of
these Foods now but this would give them
thirty dollars more to buy more of them
restricted just to Fresh local food
fruits and vegetables
and
with respect to the onus that the
program brings with it
this benefits not only women and
children and local farmers
and I think we ought to leave it to the
to the potential participants to decide
for themselves whether participation in
the program is worth it to them
or not
but it has the potential to benefit both
women and children and our farm families
uh
finally
and now I have lost my train of thought
and apologize
um
no I really have lost my train of
thought so
I I will leave it there it's it's a
useful program for both oh and what I
was trying to remember was we had
testify testimony before the Committees
that not only will this benefit farmers
markets and farm stands in the country
but most of our urban areas have farmers
markets and farm stands locally like the
one that takes place right outside the
Capitol Building here so they're
accessible to far more people than just
those who can actually get to a Farm
Stand
so for all of those reasons I would ask
you to press the green button and pass
this small but very significant benefit
for those who need it thank you as a
member of yield the questions
I do not remember does not yield
the motion before us is
a division has been requested
representative but senate representative
Senator natasto has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
motion before is a lot of pastels
amended on House Bill 574 FNA this is a
roll call vote
chair recognizes representative Leyland
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that this program was
discontinued because of low utilization
and if I know that we can access ten
dollars in one-time funding without
contributing more than just some
employer time but that this bill
appropriates three hundred thousand
dollars to increase that benefit to
thirty dollars for about twelve hundred
twelve thousand families
and if I know that there is already
access to fresh fruits and produce would
I then press the red button thank you
which I recognize representative Weber
for a parliamentary inquiry
Mr Speaker
I know
the program benefits women
and children and farmers and that the
people who need the benefit it's a big
benefit
if I know that people women and Farmers
ought to be able to choose for
themselves whether to participate in a
program that might benefit them or not
and if I know that if they choose not to
participate this is a program that will
return any sums not drawn and the money
isn't drawn until after
they use the benefit
it will be returned so
no harm no foul if it's not completely
utilized I urge you to press the green
button for the benefit that this will
give to women children and Farmers thank
you
the motion before us is auto pass is
amended on House Bill 574 or FNA this is
a roll call vote you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
president had an opportunity to vote
I also attend state of the vote
180 house will be in order 180 voting a
184 voting a committee report fails
for what reason
for what reason is a member rise I'll
move in expedient to legislate
I would like to move the table Mr
Speaker I would like to move to table
table is in order
the motion before us is to
the table House Bill 574 every division
has been requested
all members take your seats
a division a a tabling motion has been
brought forward on House Bill 574. this
is a division vote
foreign
House Bill 574 this is a division vote
for in favor you'll press a green button
of your opposal press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
foreign
also attend the state of the vote
under an 81 voting yay 183 voting a the
cabling motion failed
question is now on the motion of IPL the
house bill 574.
are you ready for the question
the division has been requested
members should be in your seats
spell the motion before us is IPO on
House Bill 574. this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your oppose you'll press
the red button boarding stations are
open for 30 seconds
foreign
partial
how would you like to vote
thank you
yeah
that's interesting here
all members president had an opportunity
to vote I also attend the state of the
vote
185 voting yay 179 voting a b committed
report of itl is adopted
he was kind
of
sweet
the committee on Health Human Services
and elderly Affairs which was referred
Hospital 614 F and an act directing the
Department of Health and Human Services
to develop a health outcomes repository
related to per and polyfluorinated
alcohol substances having considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Erica Leon for the
committee the committee amendment is
zero five three three h
printed on house Record 12 on page 57
the questions on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
hello supposedly
eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the question now is on the committee
report of ought to pass what amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
all those suppose nay
the eyes have it and the report is
adopted
and House Bill 614 is referred to the
committee on finals
foreign
the committee on labor industrial and
rehabilitative services to which was
referred House Bill 57 FM
relative to the state minimum hourly
rate comes to us without recommendation
representative Sullivan moves ought to
pass the member from Manchester
representative infants on is recognized
to speak against the motion
thank you Mr Speaker I am fortunate
enough to be on a national board where I
get to travel around the country three
times a year
and talk with my fellow insurance agents
I know really an exciting group um but
they all know that we have the largest
legislature and ask if it's unwieldily
or how we get along and I said it's very
well organized and we get a tremendous
amount accomplished every Bill gets to
see the light of day gets heard and then
brings to the floor
that's just kind of the New Hampshire
way
we get things done
we don't necessarily need government to
do it for us some examples in the state
of New Hampshire
we don't have a requirement over age 18
to wear seat belts but more of us do
than in states where it's required
we don't require people to have
insurance but more people have it than
in states that are not and we are the
only state in New England at least I
believe so that doesn't have a bottle
bill because we recycle on our own
so there's many things that the state of
New Hampshire does on their own and the
people do themselves
and when it comes to the minimum wage I
look at what business has done over the
last number of years
business needs to stay in business
business will adapt business will change
and they've had to do so by increasing
wages
and I think they've been very effective
at increasing wages
you all drive around you see a fast food
advertising between fifteen and
Seventeen dollars an hour the radio on
the way up here this morning advertising
35 dollars an hour to be on a um
a Paving crew
and now the newest thing is work today
get paid tomorrow have you seen those
advertisements so businesses will adapt
and have done so and they brought the
wages up
we don't have a minimum wage here that
is true we follow the federal minimum
wage
our two senators had the ability to
raise the minimum wage in one of the
coveted bills
and when it came to a vote on one of the
Amendments brought in by the senator
from Vermont
they chose not to
another thing about this bill is
something I was taught never to do by
some of these people in the front row
when I was a young in here
never vote for something and tie another
legislature to it
this bill has
a automatic increase based on
the
CPI
to the minimum wage
and the way I always taught we do not
tie another legislature we vote we vote
up or down we stand behind our vote we
don't just let something automatically
happen
for those reasons
I feel that business has done a better
job than government could when it comes
to wages
we have one of the lowest unemployment
in the country
where the top third of wage earners in
the state in the country
and we shouldn't be
tying any automatic increase to anything
I would ask you to vote against the
motion
for a further motion thank you does a
member yield for a question
I will answer one question
you may inquire
thank you for taking my question
leave
that I
did a research for a year and a half
looking at businesses and uh walking
around and ask workers they still make
some people they still making 7.25 an
hour
and then we have a homeless
people they they have two to three jobs
and they still don't make enough to pay
rent
and then
can you can you play explains to me how
else to spend for a minute so I know we
do would you believe questions and if I
was parliamentary God they wouldn't
happen but
you're really stretching that you can't
start out
I just want to ask you a question
because
can I ask the question if you can ask
just ask the question please yes
um
do you know how many businesses they
they they still make it they pay in 725
workers and we have people they they
still work in two or three jobs and 725
an hour and they're homeless at this
point
there are still some jobs in the state
of New Hampshire where employers are
paying 7.25 they usually last for a week
or two to make sure the employee is
going to to at least continue to show up
they're what we call the training wage
um so I'm not going to sit here and say
there's not one person one business and
one employee
um not making 7.25 an hour I wish they
all were making more but again some of
those are trading wages and others the
city of Manchester
made a decision themselves that they
weren't going to pay any of their
employees more under 15 an hour and I'm
in favor of that and for those nine
people that had helped I'm glad it did
but I'm glad the city of Manchester made
that decision and private employers made
that decision versus the government
okay
remember the member from Concord
representative Schultz is recognized to
speak in support of the motion
thank you Mr Speaker and honorable
colleagues I'm going to be
uncharacteristically brief
um
I know that's kind of hard I wrote it
down so I would be
um I want to make two core points and
that's it the first one I think
everybody
can appreciate and that's that there's
strong bipartisan support for the 15
minimum wage but among granite spaders
and the second one is about the value of
personal responsibility and hard work
as inspired by President Ronald Reagan
who I will be quoting
and that contributing to society is is a
Central American value
so first
there is full laughter poll has shown
that the average Granite stator
including a majority of Republican Rank
and file voters in New Hampshire support
raising or returning a minimum wage back
to New Hampshire and getting to 15. this
has been polled after so it's not some
radical thing we're throwing on people
this is actually something that if we
talk when we talk to our constituents we
can ask them and we'll find that to be
the case
um
and really I think it's because not only
are granted Staters smart
um but they also see that we are on a
path the neighbors our neighboring
states are on a path to get to 15 and
some employers are on that path as as
our previous speaker did point to
right now other than New Hampshire
all other New England states are on a
path to 15 and it ranges from Vermont
13.18 an hour to Massachusetts and
Connecticut are already at 15.
um so and also on this same point that's
because over a hundred and one thousand
Granite Staters make less than 15 an
hour a hundred and one thousand granted
Staters that are workers make less than
fifteen dollars an hour that is about 25
percent less than that figure was two
years ago but it's still a lot of people
and probably in every one of our
district okay so there's there's that
broad point now to the Ronald Reagan
stuff
um
of course Ronald Reagan spoke eloquently
about America being The Shining City on
the hill
and he spoke eloquently about the value
of hard work and and how we if we're
able-bodied and able-minded should be
able to contribute to society and I
think that's a bipartisan value I really
do but no one has more eloquently said
this than
President Reagan and he said
two quotes
first wouldn't it be better or the human
spirit and for the soul of this nation
to encourage people to accept more
responsibility
I agree with that and then he also says
meaningful work not welfare
is every American's hope
and we have a continuing responsibility
to make those hopes a lasting reality
I don't know that I agree with every
aspect of that and yet I do agree with
the core message of that and that's what
inspires me to keep fighting this battle
that we have yet to succeed on
and that's because American society
still holds that value we all do I
believe probably everybody in this room
I believe does I really do believe that
because if you can work
you should work we need you to work
and all jobs that need to be filled
should we should work to fill those jobs
but the minimum wage is only there as a
floor and our floor right now is much
much much too low when we default for
the Federal
seven dollars and 25 cents an hour
it was never meant to do anything to
bring broad prosperity to everybody it
was just meant to keep people out of
dire poverty
but we know workers in New Hampshire at
a much higher rate than any of us would
like have to go on public assistance
while working full-time because too many
employers pay such a low wage that they
have no other recourse
if they want to raise children if they
want to participate in society and
they're doing everything that Society is
asking of them they are not looking for
a handout
it is up to us and our responsibility to
make sure that
low-wage Granite Staters do not have to
go on public assistance
let me say that again
they're paid so low that they have to go
on public assistance and that is not
what it's for
both social safety nets are for people
who cannot work people who are sick
people who are too young or too old to
work or have a disability that causes
them to not be able to work
none of that none of our social safety
nets were to be a way to augment wages
because an employer can hit the floor or
close to the floor of the wage or the
minimum wage
moreover in terms of prosperity
every dollar that'll that a lower wage
worker earns ends up back in this
economy I think that's true of most
middle class families do it's a rising
tide that lifts all boats
for people earning low wages and for A
Hard Day's Work all they really are
asking for is that fair wage
and we need to ensure that it happened
because again none of them wants a
handout
I come from a family of hard workers I'm
sure given that we do this as volunteers
I bet we all come from families that are
hard workers and again no worker wants a
handout
so for that modest
um for their hard work they deserve that
modest pay as a means of contributing to
society and we need to do the right
thing and raise that floor at least to
the minimum of what our neighbors are
going towards and that's what the first
step of this bill would do
I'm skipping over a lot of points to
keep it brief
um
okay for me for me okay in all fairness
um so I hope that you will
um support this bill by
um
what is the motion ought to pass good
okay
um please vote to pass this bill by uh
choosing The Color of Money the green
button thank you for your time
representative santanostaza requests a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
foreign
this will be a roll call vote member
sticker seats
foreign
representative seaworth is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that increasing the minimum wage
every year for well forever is bad
policy for New Hampshire and if I heard
that it's very similar legislation just
got voted down on the other side of the
wall would I not press the red button to
defeat this motion so a better motion
can be made
representative Sullivan is recognized
for parliamentary incorrect
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that New Hampshire
has no minimum wage but follows the
federal minimum wage of 7.25 an hour
and if I also know
that all
all the other New England states are
well on their way towards a 15 minimum
wage if not already there
if I further know that HP 57 would store
a New Hampshire minimum wage in between
two at fifteen dollars over 50 over
three years would I then hit the green
button to support New Hampshire workers
thank you
the question is on the motion of ought
to pass on House Bill 57 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
100 balloon
representative
there
represent woodcock
comes up and thumbs down please thank
you
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
178 in the affirmative 183 on the
negative the motion fails
for what reason does remember us
move in expedient to legislate
representative Sweeney moves expedient
to legislator and for what reason does
the other member rise
thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to make a
motion to table and I'd request the
division
no no
representative address moves that house
the Astro division okeydoke
moves that house bill 57 be laid on the
table
this will be a division vote members all
in your seats right
foreign
House Bill 57 on the table this is a
division vote if you are in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
thank you
of all members Presidents had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
183 in the in the 180 in the affirmative
183 and the negative the motion fails
question now is on the motion of
inexperience to legislate are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it
probably 183 to 180.
foreign
labor industrial and rehabilitative
services to which was prepared House
Bill 74 FN relative to an employee's
unused earned time comes to us without
recommendation representative Cahill
moves ought to pass
the member from Manchester
representative infantein is recognized
to speak against the motion
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker
as we all know business owners provide
benefits to their employees for a
mechanism to entice them to come to work
for them to keep them to stay working
for them to keep them happy in their in
their jobs
uh vacations sick time benefits these
are all very laudable things
one of the hard things in the labor
committee
is trying to make a law that fits
everyone
sometimes unfortunately it ends up not
fitting anyone
because we have businesses of all shapes
and sizes
large multinational companies large New
Hampshire based and New Hampshire owned
companies medium companies small
companies startups research and
development all kinds of different
things where people have one employee
two employees
so it's very difficult to try to set
everything into one little package
because it doesn't always work out very
well
we have tried our best over the years in
the labor committee
to let businesses make some of their own
decisions on how they're going to
offer benefits
some offer vacation time sick pay some
don't even call it that they call it pay
time off it's a certain number of hours
you can use it how you see fit
for vacation if you need extra sick time
so trying to put everything into that
one little package and tell everybody
you're going to have to do something
you're going to have to offer vacation
time sick time and then if there's any
kind of departure
get fired quit and he's then you must
now take those benefits that you gave
and pay cash on the barrelhead right now
within seven days just like its wages
well some employers don't consider them
as wages
I'm going to provide these to you and I
hope you will stay employed with me
I don't want you to come to work and
then
like some some businesses will decide in
their their manual yes we will pay you
that on a pro rata basis
a certain amount of time so if you do
leave our employment doesn't cease
you get a certain program of those
benefits
others say no because we have seasonal
businesses we have businesses that are
just busy on weekends versus during the
week it's all kinds of different
machinations of what businesses do those
owners make the decisions on how that's
going to affect them we've heard horror
stories about people saying I'll give
you two weeks paid vacation they work
five days into the new year and then
they want their two weeks paid vacation
that's why we allow businesses to make
some of these decisions on their own
so while I I do respect the sponsor of
this bill for trying to do something I
think he's just tried to make it too
narrow he's trying to tell too many
businesses what to do it and I don't
think it's our decision
to tell businesses how to do this so I
respectfully ask you to vote against the
motion on the table
the member from Newmarket representative
Cahill is recognized to speak in support
of the motion
thank you Mr Speaker
imagine if you will you're not sitting
in reps Hall
you're sitting in the break room
of your current employer
and let's say that the people on that
side of the room
were laid off uh
almost 2 30. today's your last day
you had no idea this was coming but
today is your last day you've been a
great employee but you're being laid off
people in the middle uh your Situation's
a little different because you know
you've done well with the company but
for whatever reason you're moving on to
maybe you're relocating you're doing
something else and you know you're
giving your notice so that that your
boss can find a replacement maybe you've
even helped training that person you're
leading on good terms you weren't fired
you're living on good terms
over here I'm sorry I've sold the
business
and I've sold the business and while
it's customary and you might expect
recently expect that if you're you're
staying on you're going to work for that
company and your hours your vacation
hours will travel with you
I'm sorry that's not happening because
in New Hampshire I'm allowed to say
we don't pay vacation hours at
termination it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter you're a good employee that's not
your fault it's beyond your control it
doesn't matter in New Hampshire
that's what I can do it so I'm going to
do it
and you know when when you interviewed
for the job and I said you know this is
how much I'm going to pay you we had
health insurance we have you know two
weeks vacation and uh
and here here's the Personnel matter
policy book and you probably didn't read
it because who does who reads those you
know terms and conditions but down the
bottom and there's some place that said
this little this little blurb we don't
pay upon termination
so I don't I don't happen to think it's
fair that under the circumstances I've
outlined I'm you you're laid off you get
you worked hard you gave you notice did
everything the employer ever asked you
to do and probably a bit more
and when you're looking at that final
pay stub
you're comparing it with your last one
something is missing and that's your
vacation hours whether you call it PTO
vacation whatever it was called it's
gone
and now you're going to go down to the
unemployment office and you're going to
say I I my job is over and uh I'm gonna
have to get by with uh 60 sorry 30 of
what I was making up to a maximum for
uh that's what I'm gonna that's what I
have to do because I didn't get my
vacation pay
and the vacation pay you know maybe you
have three to five thousand dollars
saved up to pay your mortgage your your
rent or your food expenses and maybe you
don't
but having that vacation pay would
certainly make a difference
so I'm going to tell you now that um
that the employer should wipe out this
item from his from his balance sheet put
the money in his pocket
uh vacation weighs that is theft
thank you Mr libertarian so uh so I
would like you to vote
ought to pass on this bill so we can
move it to the other body and we'll see
what kind of rationale they have I think
I want you to remember that you vote
that you represent not only the
businesses in your community you work
you represent the workers in your
community
and if we don't pass this at some point
somebody working in your community will
come to you and say you know I called
the labor board and they say That's the
Law that's the law and you had a chance
to change it why didn't you change it
thank you Mr Speaker
representative Santa nostalto has
requested a roll call which has already
required seconds
this will be a roll call vote members
take the seats
the question is on the motion about to
pass on House Bill 74. representative
infantshine is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that one size fits all rarely
fits anyone
and the businesses have the ability
to determine what their benefits are and
how they're going to allot them
dependent upon the size and scope of
their business would I please vote
against the motion on the floor for a
future motion thank you Mr Speaker
representative Sullivan's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that many New Hampshire
employers do pay for earned vacation
time on termination
but if I also know
that New Hampshire employers are allowed
to take a pass on paying for that unused
vacation time when employee is laid off
generated in good standing or if the
company is sold
if I also know that HB 74 will require
all employers to pay for that earned
vacation time
in such circumstances
would I then press the green button in
favor of New Hampshire workers thank you
the question is on the motion of ought
to pass on House Bill 74. this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
foreign
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
187 in the affirmative 174 in the
negative the motion is adopted
and House Bill 74 is referred to the
committee on finance
foreign
County government to which was referred
House Bill 489 FNA
also be in order
and act establishing a County
terrorism Development Fund
ministered by Department of Business and
economic Affairs and making an
appropriation therefore considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is in expedient
to legislate Senator Richard lasalles
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass don't worry stop us with a minority
of the committee
chair recognizes representative
magliore
to speak against the committee report
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues if you want to help bring
more tourism dollars to New Hampshire
and assist our counties with tourism
development then I ask you to vote
against the Ito motion on HB 489 so that
another motion can be made
business
currently markets and promotes all New
Hampshire all of New Hampshire and
typically highlights the most well-known
tourist spots
the department does not currently have
the resources and Personnel to Target
individual counties
or necessarily emphasize the unique
tourism opportunities of a specific
County
some counties need a little more help
than others to bring tourists and tax
dollars to their own beautiful places of
interest
this new Operational Support Program
managed through Bea would make grant
money available to County governments to
assist with operational costs of their
tourism development efforts funds
appropriated for the Operational Support
Program would not lapse
will be administered by the travel and
tourism Department
and be required to meet established
reporting requirements counties by doing
some marketing and highlighting events
happening in their own counties on their
own will help our businesses by bringing
in more tourists
in turn they will grow County tax
revenues and ultimately bring in more
Revenue to our state it has been said
through testimony that for every one
dollar spent on New Hampshire tourism
promotion we get upwards of thirteen
dollars in return
so you can see this is a great
opportunity to provide benefits and
growth for our tourism activity I hope
that you can see the value to County
government in this program please join
the bipartisan effort to Spur terrorism
in our state by overturning the itl
motion so that another motion can be
made thank you Mr Speaker and I request
a division vote
share recognized representative power
thank you Mr Speaker I rise in support
of the committee recommendation of
inexpedient to legislate on house spell
489.
this bill establishes a county tourism
Development Fund administered by the
division of travel and tourism
development within the New Hampshire
Department of Business and economic
affairs
additionally this bill establishes a
county tourism grant program to be used
by individual counties for the purpose
of promoting and developing County
tourism initiatives
the majority of the committee feels that
this legislation is unnecessary for a
number of reasons first currently there
exists two initiatives the travel and
tourism Development Fund and the joint
operational program both administered by
the New Hampshire Department of Business
and economic Affairs for the purpose of
promoting and developing tourism travel
and tourism across the entire Granite
State
second
the website
visitnewhampshire.org.gov produced by
these existing authorities already does
an excellent job of showcasing travel
and tourism across the entire Granite
State including destinations in all 10
New Hampshire counties
clearly this bill is not needed as
tourism and travel is already well
funded and promoted by the state of New
Hampshire
in conclusion this bill grows government
unnecessarily and it fails to justify
expenditures against measurable benefits
for these reasons I urge my fellow
colleagues to support the committee
recommendation of inexpedient to
legislate by voting yes on House Bill
489. thank you Mr Speaker
representative Senator toastown has
called for a roll call with this
sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your seats
foreign
okay
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of inexp legislation
house bill 489. this also be an order
this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative Magnolia for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that travel and tourism is an
economic driver that is beneficial to
our entire State economy and Mr Speaker
if I know that the Department of
Business and economic Affairs supports
this bill to Spur travel and tourism
development unique in each County
and Mr Speaker if I believe that a 13 to
1 return on investment is significant
and Mr Speaker if I believe that
overturning the itl will allow the
introduction of important new
information with an amendment then Mr
Speaker would I allow my finger to
travel to the red button to overturn the
itl so that we may explore another
option thank you Mr Speaker
okay
chair recognize
here recognized representative power for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
I know that both funding and programming
for the purpose of promoting and
developing travel and tourism across the
entire Granite State already exists
and is administered by the New Hampshire
Department of Business and economic
Affairs and if I know that the State
website visit New Hampshire
dot gov does an excellent job at
showcasing travel and tourism across the
entire Granite State including all
destinations in all 10 counties what I
now now vote Yes to support the
committee recommendation of inexpedient
to legislate and push the green button
thank you Mr Speaker
motion before us is the majority
committee report of an expedite
legislative and House Bill 489 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
to press the red button warning stations
are open for 30 seconds
all members president an opportunity to
evoke also tend to save the vote
190 voting a 171 voting May committee
report is adopted
committee on resource Recreation
development to which was referred House
Bill 212 FNA an act appropriating
funding for investigations testing and
monitoring relative to pair and poly
floral alcohol substances considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation to build a lot of pass
Senator Rosemary rung for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
12th May
guys have it the committee report is
adopted and it's on its way to finance
community on resource and Recreation
development to which was referred House
Bill 276 FNA act establishing a rhino
bacteria mitigation Loan Fund having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation of a lot of paths with
Amendment and rosemary Run for the
committee the amendment is zero four one
eight H Clinton and house Record 12
pages 41-43 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say aye
can I propose day
guys have it the amendment is adopted
the question before us now is on the
bill ought to pass with Amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes
division has been requested members take
your seats
in your seat
motion before us is ought to pass with
Amendment
Voice vote was taken I'm sure division
was called for this will be a division
vote member must be in the seats
this will be a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
to reopose You'll press a red button
according stations are open for 30
seconds
foreign
was president had an opportunity to vote
how to attend the state of the vote
199 voting a 160 voting a committee
report is adopted and it's on its way to
finance
foreign
development
in which was referred House Bill 534 FNA
relative to water assistance for natural
disasters considered the same report the
same with the recommendation of Bill
lock to pass you know Susanville for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same in being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that is in
its meaning to legislate and of Juliet
Harvey Ebola of the minority of the
committee
chair recognizes representative Harvey
Ebola
speak against the committee report
thank you Mr Speaker
um
I Rise uh
speak about the purpose of uh House Bill
534 is to provide financial assistance
to low-income homeowners served by
residential Wells that are experiencing
water supply problems due to drought
this bill increases funding from a
temporary 1.5 million dollar fund to a 5
million dollar fund over the next two
fiscal years it will be managed by the
Department of Environmental Services
I'm asking you to vote against this bill
for two reasons number one New Hampshire
is no longer in a drought
the good news is that according to both
uh Haley the point from WMUR and the U.S
drought monitor report New Hampshire has
been 100 drought-free since January
returning us to replenishment levels not
seen since 2020 and following a trend of
improvement since the fall of last year
additionally New Hampshire should
anticipate being drought-free all the
way through early June according to data
prepared for the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration for the U.S
seasonal drought Outlook
we trust the science we won't need this
fund
number two
second reason to vote against this bill
is it doesn't fit into the stated
mission of Des
the protection and wise management of
the state's environment are the main
goals of the agency
is a stated mission for Des and at this
they do a great job
the Water Division is tasked with
protecting our numerous lakes ponds
rivers and groundwater according to
their website
but the administration of a welfare
program such as this water assistance
program is an expansion of their mission
and introduces a new kind of welfare
help is already available from
traditional welfare departments an
emergency loan is available to
homeowners suffering from dry Wells
through their Town welfare department
additionally extra funds are available
through Elder services for those who
qualify our community action programs
that already oversee utility emergency
services would be a more suitable
program for the administration of
emergency
Well Repair funding
so I would urge you to itl thank you
Joe recognize representative
thank you Mr Speaker and good afternoon
honorable colleagues
natural disasters such as flout floods
and droughts are occurring more often
we have had more frequent storms that
have brought inches of water at a time
and we have had derived spells in New
Hampshire that last for weeks
particularly last summer which was
gorgeous
New Hampshire may be going into its
fourth drought in four years and we must
wait to see if that happens again
when a homeowner loses the use of their
well they have no water supply and it
may have or have may not have the
resources to explore and to remediate
the problem
the cost and the logistics of replacing
a well in an emergency can be
prohibitive
but private well owners have been
applying for funds through the New
Hampshire drinking water and groundwater
trust fund advisory committee
since 2020 the New Hampshire drinking
water and groundwater trust fund has
helped
147 homeowners repair replace and or
treat their Wells secondary to drought
and flood conditions and other natural
disasters that have occurred
the trust fund however is not able to
replenish funds for this well-documented
need one that is coming to us year after
year since the fund was created
so what this bill does is it creates a
dedicated long non-lapsing fund called
the water assistance for national
disasters fund and it appropriates two
and a half million dollars for the
fiscal year ending in 2024
and two and a half million dollars for
the fiscal year ending in 2025
as it is written
from this program private well owners
will be able to apply for assistance in
the form of a loan or a grant via Des so
that in the event of a natural disaster
they will be able to replace replayer or
treat their well as needed the loans and
grants are based on the ability to pay
the income guidelines are not fixed it
is Rule making Authority that Des has in
order to to assist with this money and
they will be using a process that is
already in existence
Des may also apply for and accept from
any source
gifts donations of money federal grants
legislative Appropriations local
and other
matching funds that that also
can be deposited into this dedicated and
non-lapsing fund
so I leave you just with the comment
that Equitable access to clean water
is something that will benefit all
Granite Staters and I hope that you will
vote in favor of the bill please push
the green button thank you
representative veal has requested a
division members take your seats
here
motion before us the majority committee
report of on a pass on House Bill 534
this is a division vote
chair recognizes the representative her
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that the majority
rejected a proposal to study how this
bill would fit into other available
programs such as federal aid or
emergency welfare Aid that may be
presently available to assure drinking
water for our taxpayers
and if I know that this bill proposes to
provide water assistance for natural
disasters yet the bill itself reveals a
plan to spend five million dollars to
repair and replace Wells only for a
select group of our taxpayers
and if I know that a natural disaster in
a natural disaster all New Hampshire
taxpayers should be treated equally
then would I not press the red button so
another motion can be made thank you Mr
Speaker
recognizes representative Darby for a
parliamentary
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that New Hampshire
has experienced severe drought
conditions over the last three years
leading to dry Wells and well water
contamination for many households
particularly in the North country and
Southern Tier of the state and Mr
Speaker if I know that this bipartisan
bill is modeled on an earlier program by
the drinking water and groundwater trust
fund which helped many needy families
whose Wells were affected by natural
disasters over the last two years to
stay in their homes thereby lessening
the housing crisis and Mr Speaker if I
know the fund would be well managed by
New Hampshire Des based on publicly
adopted rules defining natural disasters
and ensuring recipients have exhausted
all other options before qualifying for
financial assistance wouldn't I press
the green button in support of houseboat
534 thank you Mr Speaker
motion before us the majority committed
report about a pass on House Bill 534.
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button of
your opposed or press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
the babes
foreign
was president had an opportunity to vote
also attend the state of the vote
179 40da 177 voting a committee report
is adopted and it's on its way to
finance
thank you
we're moving on to part two of the
calendar
majority of the committee on children
and family law to which was referred
House Bill 108 act relative to the
confidentiality of reports made to the
division of children youth and families
requiring Guardians at the item to be
appointed in certain instances have been
considered the same report that the same
with the recommendation to build a lot
of paths with Senator Mark Pearson for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee haven't
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate
and if David Bickford for the minority
of the committee
for what reason does a memberize
sorry
chair recognizes uh
representative Moulton
sorry about that I didn't realize it was
my turn
um
thank you Mr go ahead
thank you Mr Speaker
sorry I'm new at this
um
I would like to speak in support of
House Bill 108. uh this bill is would
attach a penalty to uh people who are
making a report in bad faith keep that
in mind in bad faith to dcyf I'm a
mandated reporter all adults in New
Hampshire are mandated reporters all you
need is a suspicion of abuse or neglect
to make a report in good faith
there's a difference between making a
report in good faith or in bad faith
this is not going to penalize people who
are making a report in good faith the
determination of if it's a good faith
report or if it's a bad faith report is
done through dcyf that is that is on
them to determine
if it's a bad faith report or not it
takes a lot there's a high bar for them
to determine without a shadow of a doubt
um if the report was made in bad faith
50 states and territories have similar
bills uh similar laws uh to this on
their on the record
um I am in support of this because I
think that by having similar legislation
done here it will deter people who are
making bad faith reports it should not
the intention of this bill is not to
deter good faith reporting
it is to deter the bad faith reporting
if they know that there's going to be
criminal penalties attached they might
not make that report but people who are
still making a report in good faith have
nothing to worry about I am in support
of this bill if you feel the same then
please push the green button
chair recognizer representative Bickford
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise in opposition
to this idea
this is about child abuse neglect and
about reporting as the young lady told
us that every one of us needs to report
this think about what happens
when people think that they might be
prosecuted
you don't know what happens after you've
made a report it's you it's not
uh in the public domain right criminal
cases are so you make a report that
something's happening next door down the
street wherever teachers have to do this
quite often you can do it confidentially
but the thing is it's confidential
afterwards so you don't know the next
time
you make a report whether anything
happened or not and so you may make a
series of reports and then suddenly
somebody decides at dcyf that well I
think we're getting too many reports
but you were told you were supposed to
make reports just on suspicion
we all remember what happened
with the Roman Catholic Church when many
of us were afraid to make reports
because of the authority
it's important to get those reports out
um and not suppress the free speech of
the public that would make those uh
reports just recently we had a child die
in uh I think it was Manchester oh lice
I don't know if anybody did report that
but those are the sort of things we
desperately need people to report to
dcyf which Division of Youth children
and families and so that they can
investigate those things
we're not going to know if they have bad
faith or not it's up to them to
um to sort that out
we we just want those reports to come in
we've been that way for many years ever
since we went to this chapter and we
thought
this outweighs not Prosecuting people
not letting them think that they might
become uh uh a suspect they have to go
before court
we don't want them to think that they'll
get their mug shot just for reporting
innocently just
yes
yes just you could make an innocent
report and be suspect
and if you're suspect you can be
prosecuted
a mug shot
and that's why we didn't want to go this
direction we want people to feel free
you're going to have to hire a defense
attorney it's going to cost you daily
and when the word gets out
people are not going to freely report
it's going to rain it in they're going
to back off
and that's what we're afraid of doing so
I'd like to ask you to not support the
bill as it is
first the red button so that we can
continue on in New Hampshire the way we
have we've done a pretty good job
but we can do better
and if we go this way
we won't be doing a good job thank you
yeah recognizing representative Mark
Pearson
thank you Mr Speaker
um several of the points I was going to
make were actually made better by my
colleagues so I'll skip some points and
just say a few things
over the years some people I've been
charged with looking after
have been the victims of a disgruntled
ex-spouse using his or her children to
get revenge by making intentionally
false reports of child abuse to the
relevant Department Court law
enforcement agency or Social Service
Agency the bill before us would add
finally New Hampshire to the long list
of states and territories that say you
do that and you'll be punished for it
the statutes in these and other
jurisdictions all include such phrases
as knowingly and willfully
makes a false report
another state says the person knew that
the report was false or was made with
Reckless disregard of the truth or
falsity of the report in other words an
honest mistake is not punished
the question was raised as to whether
the addition of this law would have a
deleterious effect on honest sincere
reporting those consulted in other
states tell us they do not believe their
laws had that effect
therefore out of an abundance of caution
the bill before us specifically adds a
section
indemnifying those who make a good faith
but inaccurate report
Mr Speaker let's take one weapon out of
the hands of those who would use their
children to Strike Back At a next spouse
thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of want to pass on
House Bill 108.
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested members
take your seats
motion before us is the majority
committee report of water pass on House
Bill 108. this is a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
grade for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that this body has the safety
and well-being of children as a priority
and if I know that this bill could deter
conscientious citizens for making a
pertinent call to protect children and
if I also know that there is already
legal recourse for defamation and
slander would I now press the red button
and vote no on deterring calls to report
potential abuse or neck or neglect thank
you
Geo recognized from Senator Pearson for
parliamentary inquiry
Mr Speaker if I know that the penalty is
for making a false report of child abuse
are on the books in the vast majority of
States but not yet New Hampshire
and if I know that those who make a good
face but inaccurate report are
indemnified in this bill
and finally if I know that laws like the
one under consideration have not led to
people being afraid to make reports when
necessary would I vote ought to pass by
pressing the green button thank you Mr
Speaker
the motion before us the majority
committed report of ought to pass on
House Bill 108 this is a division vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed or press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
the road
214 voting a 143 voting a committee
report is adopted
committee on children and family law to
which is referred House Bill 124 and act
relative to Temporary alimony have been
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation of the bill ought to
pass
Senator Deborah DeSimone for the
committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
Bill both nay
the division has been called members in
the chamber only
members take your seats
thank you
motion before us is ought to pass on
hb124
this will be a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button your opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
foreign
representative
representative panic
thumbs up or thumbs down please
thumbs up thank you
president Brown
what's up boss
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
also attend the state of the vote
179 voting a 178 voting a the committee
report is adopted
majority of the committee on children
and family law to which those referred
House Bill 151 enact establishing a
committee to study the issue of
unmarried co-inhabitants domestic
Partnerships and common law marriage
considered the same report the same in
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass in a pat long for the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpeding to legislate Senator David
Bickford with a minority of the
committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
division has been requested
members take their seats only members in
the chamber
only
oh was he
remembers take your seats
the motion before us is
majority report is ought to pass
on House Bill 151
this is a division vote
to clarify The Voice vote you're in
favor you press the green button of your
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
representative
yes or no please
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
under 99 voting yay 155 voting they
committee report is adopted
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety to Richards deferred House Bill
97 FN enact establishing an additional
penalty for a violation of privacy
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation at the bill ought to
pass Senator Jennifer Rhodes for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
no suppose nay
the eyes have it and committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on criminal
objections and Public Safety to ritual's
deferred house bill 160.
also be in order
and act relative to public display of
Chess having considered the same report
but the same the same with the following
resolution resolved that is resolved
that is inexputing to legislate
representative Jennifer Rhodes the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same the inevitable agree
with the majority report the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
General Jason joggin for the minority of
the committee
the motion before us is
Pierre recognizes
representative Haynes Hines
thank you Mr Speaker this is the simple
bill that codifies state law and
clarifies it under state law anyone can
be in public without a shirt or top and
is not illegal if you go to Hampton
Beach during the summer you will see
many men out there without a shirt on
you will also see some women without a
top on there have been no issues I would
suggest if someone is harassing people
that the harasser is the person who
should be held responsible and not the
victim
we're in spite of state law allowing
this the City of Laconia has an
ordinance preventing it now I took that
ordinance challenged it to the New
Hampshire Supreme Court on equal
protection grounds because Laconia
ordinance said men can be outside
without a shirt on but women can be
cannot unfortunately I lost that Supreme
Court decision by a vote of three to two
um further evidence that every vote
counts uh we know that by some of the
ties here today
but I'd suggest uh we can overrule that
so New Hampshire is a Dillon State not a
home rule state what that means is towns
and cities can only do what the state
gives them permission to do and the
state can preempt the town and we do
this in many areas I expect half of the
room here is proud that we preempt towns
on firearm laws and don't let towns
regulate that and the other half of the
room I would suspect if there was a bill
that prevented towns from Banning
abortions at any moment in time that
that might be something that people
would also be in favor of
so depending on the issue there are many
examples where we do not allow towns to
do what we want what they want there's a
minimum floor that this legislative body
sets
um and so when there are enabling bills
um that allows towns to do something we
can say no you cannot do that and I
would suggest that our enabling statutes
do say that towns cannot do things that
are repugnant to the Constitution as
suggest it is repugnant to the
Constitution to make a crime help an
element based on someone's sex we would
not even hopefully consider ever having
a crime that has an element someone's
race and I would suggest it's just as
wrong to do it when it's based on
someone's sex
I don't believe there's testimony
against this in the committee however
it's my understanding the nhma
um didn't take a position as to towns
doing it in discriminatory fashion
um but their concern was well what if
towns don't want people or what if towns
want to require shirts in town hall or
Library I think that makes sense um Town
should be able to do that if they want
um so my position is solely when towns
are doing it in a discriminatory fashion
based on someone's sex so I'd ask that
you vote against the itl so that a
additional language that has been
presented we can Abode that which would
address that
and I just want to say freedom should
not depend on someone's sex whether Live
Free or Die State we're not to live for
your diet unless you're a female State
thank you
chair recognize representative Roy
thank you Mr Speaker
the committee voted on this
we thought about it it's
it was a difficult one but at the end of
the day we came down on the position of
what is going on at the moment in a
particular town is something that we
cannot foresee or interfere in if the
citizens of Laconia they have bike week
they have different events
they as a citizenry decide that this is
what's best for our town at this
particular moment in the safety of our
town they decided that was the way they
wanted to go this is not something that
we feel we should micromanage towns on
other issues as the previous speaker
said are more important this one really
it's just I guess I would say that it's
a difficult one for us to get involved
in at the state level because different
towns have different events all
throughout the year so I would ask you
to support the bipartisan committee vote
to let the towns deal with this in the
best way they see fit thank you
representative Reed has requested
division vote members take your seats
the motion before us is majority
committee report of inexped into
legislate a house obeying order
on House Bill 160. this is a division
vote
the chair recognizes representative Reed
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know the definition of crime should not
be based upon a person's sex and if I
know that display of chest is already
legal under state law but towns have
passed ordinances that are
discriminatory on the basis of sex
providing unequal treatment of the Sexes
under the law meaning that I could be
arrested for the same exact behavior
that would be completely illegal for you
Mr Speaker and if I know that the
municipal Association actor Consulting
the towns
thank you if I know that the municipal
Association after Consulting the towns
that have passed the discriminatory
ordinances were fine with the idea of
the legislature prohibiting towns from
passing discriminatory ordinances on the
basis of sex and finally Mr Speaker if I
know that the prime sponsor intends to
bring forward floor amendment that
simply states that towns cannot pass
ordinances that discriminate on the
basis of sex effectively solving the
concerns the committee members had then
would I now press the red button to
overturn the itl so that the floor
amendment can be brought forward and we
can end the unequal treatment of the de
Sexes under the law
chair recognized representative Rory for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that that
amendment was not brought um when we
heard the bill the committee did not
have the opportunity to hear it and
weigh it and if I further know that no
one from the public came and asked for
this bill the war showed up to testify
about this bill and finally Mr Speaker
if I know that this is something best
left up to the folks in the town what
they would do and do not want on their
streets and in their venues would I now
press the green button am I right yeah
green button to support the committee
vote thank you
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of any Expedia to
legislate on House Bill 160. this is a
division vote you're in favor you'll
press the green button of your opposal
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
foreign
all members president of an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
the vote
223 voting yay 129 voting a committee
report is adopted
majority of committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety to Richard's
referred Hospital 191.
an act relative to voluntary surrendered
Firearms having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution
resolved that it is inexpeding to
legislate
Senator Jonathan Smith for the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being any of the
degree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass and if David means for the minority
of the committee
chair recognizes representative Muse
thank you very much Mr Speaker
HP 191 is a pretty simple bill that
gives the department of safety uh the
option that's the option of offering a
firearm surrender and Destroy program
for gun owners
it recognizes the fact that there are
some gun owners who may have inherited a
firearm a required one uh at some point
who may not feel comfortable with one in
the house or who may have inherited it
from a family member and would rather
have it destroyed
the bill would change but not eliminate
a law passed 25 years ago that lets
State Police accept weapons that are
turned in by owners who no longer want
them
currently when these weapons get turned
in they're either auctioned off or the
state police can decide to keep them but
what a current law does not do is give
the state police the option the option
again and not the mandate to do what
some gun owners choose to do with their
own property and that is to Simply have
it destroyed
in theory gun owners have the right to
destroy their property on their own
while some might have access to a
shredder capable of shredding paper very
few people have access to the kind of
Shredder that's uh necessary to actually
shred a firearm or the kind of saw
that's powerful enough to cut a firearm
up so it's no longer workable or an
oxyacetylene torch capable of melting
one enough in enough of the right places
to render it inoperable
State Police are already incurring the
expense of accepting turned in weapons
and deciding how to dispose of them all
the bill does that's in front of us now
is give the state police another option
for disposing of them while at the same
time giving a few people who would like
to be ex-gun owners the comfort of
knowing that a weapon that once belonged
to them will never be in a position to
be used in an act of violence or to help
a person take their own life
the bottom line is this bill only adds
an option it's not a mandate
some people might make the argument that
criminals might take advantage of the
program to have a crime gun destroyed
but to me you actually have to be a
pretty dumb criminal to risk an
unnecessary encounter with police over
something like this
um what's also important to realize is
that allowing the state police to
provide this option is no more costly
than administering the options that we
already provide there are also companies
out there like gun Busters that will
actually work with law enforcement to
destroy weapons for law enforcement at
no charge so please please support me in
supporting a bill that actually supports
the rights of people who own property to
decide how that property can and should
be disposed of again this is a bill that
does not require the state police to
implement this program it merely would
give them the option of doing it thank
you
chair recognizes representative Roy
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker we heard
testimony on this bill from the state
police the state police are the ones who
brought up the idea that it could
possibly be
um The Perfect Crime if you use a gun
you bring it into the state police and
they destroy it for you well there goes
the case
as often or not as that may happen it's
not as important as the fact that
destroying perfectly good property that
can be converted to money for the town
or the city or the state is the reason
this law was put in place in the first
place if a citizen wants their firearm
destroyed rather than sold they just
want it out of commission any number of
gunsmiths in the state would be happy to
do it for a very small fee as much as it
would break their heart
having said that there's just no reason
for this bill at this time and the
Firearms are currently being dealt with
however the owners want them to be and
if they're not someone's happy to do it
thank you
motion before us is the majority
committee report of ink speech to
legislate
Health Bill
191 synonym has asked for a roll call it
is sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote members take your seats
foreign
Expedia to legislative House Bill 191
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative Muse
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know this bill would only give the
department of safety an option to
correct a surrender and Destroy program
and not a mandate and if I know that
many other states in the local
governments provide this option as a
convenience to gun owners and if they
know that weapons are already being
surrendered to the Department of Safety
and providing this option would cost
taxpayers nothing then would I press the
red button and defeat this motion thank
you
should I recognize representative Roy
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
state police testified that they were
not really interested in this bill if I
know that no citizen came forward and
asked for this bill and if I know that
if someone brings their firearm to be
destroyed by a licensed firearm dealer
they may actually find out that it's
worth a lot of money and change their
mind which they would never find out if
they brought it to the state police and
finally Mr Speaker if I would like to
support the bipartisan vote to support
this would I vote with the committee in
pressing the green button thank you
the motion before is the majority
committee report of index Financial
legislator and House Bill 191 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
what's up
wall members president had an
opportunity to vote
also attend the state of the vote
if you're wondering 37 voting a 121
voting a committee report is adopted
chair recognizes represent adjunate for
a motion
thank you Mr Speaker I would like to
move that HB 35 from the committee on
education be special ordered to the
first order of business tomorrow morning
and I'd like to speak to the motion
thank you Mr Speaker uh the family For
Whom the uh bill was inspired by uh will
not be here today uh they will be here
tomorrow morning and as such I would ask
the house to grant them the courtesy and
ability to watch the proceedings uh and
support this motion to special order
this bill uh I know we're in the middle
of criminal justice but I'm doing it now
because of just how fast we're going
today and I don't want to accidentally
skip it so uh please support the special
order motion on hb35 for first order
tomorrow thank you
motion before us is a special order
House Bill 35 until first order of
business tomorrow
first order of business tomorrow all
those in favor say aye
if it goes May
the eyes have it
motion carries
criminal and criminal committee on
criminal justice and Public Safety to
which was referred Hospital 201 FN
relative to changing penalties for
driving without a license
it is uh without recommendation
representative moves
ought to pass Jr recognizes
representative Rhodes
speak against the committee
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker House Bill 201 will make it
possible to drive without ever obtaining
a driver's license because as we heard
and committee people may not know our
laws
having a valid driver's license is not a
New Concept there isn't a single country
that does not require some sort of
license that you obtain by demonstrating
you have the general knowledge and
understanding of the rules of the road
all by the U.S as a whole doesn't
require it but all 50 sovereign states
do
if passed this law will allow a person
to drive without ever acquiring a
driver's license
but wait there's more
in the event you were to be caught you
would have to be convicted twice in
12-month period of time for it to be
considered more than a violation
this is a blatant insult to everybody
that has made the investment to acquire
and maintain a driver's license
HP 201 isn't addressing the person that
hasn't renewed their license before it
expired and has demonstrated that they
know and have a basic understanding of
driving it is alarming a person that has
never obtained a license to justify
ignorance and disregard the law because
they decided they didn't need to follow
it
Mr Speaker this is a prime example of
someone has an excuse for everything and
takes responsibility for nothing
please vote against the ought to pass
motion so another motion can be made
do you recognize the representative
ceiling
spelling
thank you Mr Speaker and um I hope
you'll learn that I'm one of your order
speakers in general statue on and Link
um
I I move that hb201fn
ought to pass in 2015 a change was made
to increase the penalty for driving
without a license to a misdemeanor after
a single tragic accident involving an
unlicensed driver who was also driving
under the influence of Narcotics and was
significantly impaired
her major crime was in fact driving
under the influence of Narcotics and
being significantly impaired however
this law was then passed because of that
the fire offense has unintended
consequences it disproportionately
affects some New Hampshire citizens
these include single parents people who
are economically disadvantaged and
people who may be new immigrants or VISA
holders who are still learning our laws
take for example the case of a family
living in a very rural part of the state
you cannot afford to have their team
take driver's education but needs the
team to work part-time or to assist with
caring for younger siblings
the team may have learned to drive with
their family but cannot get a license
until they can afford to take driver's
education or turn 18. asked in an
emergency situation say to get
medication for covid
to go drive to the pharmacy they're
pulled over and cited for unlicensed
operation
this results in a misdemeanor offense on
their record which requires they check
the box on all job applications in the
future indicating the conviction
it will influence that team's chances
for job prospects for life
um also Imagine a single working parent
who's been able unable to take unpaid
time off from work to get to the DMV on
the two separate occasions to get their
license
who gets a Class B misdemeanor
necessitating a day in court potential
loss of employment or more college
student here on a Visa coming from a
country where they don't have driver's
licenses
before they hit on the rules they get a
car and are stopped on their first drive
a Class B misdemeanor can invalidate
their visa preventing them from
completing their education and causing a
loss of tuition payment to the
university
in a person who gets upgraded from a
moped on their very first and gets their
very first Harley-Davidson on their
birthday
they go out for a ride not realize and
they actually need a different license
than the one they already have
some will say these are fair
consequences for not knowing our laws
and for breaking them and we'll use
examples of people driving recklessly
without a license or without insurance
but they're already specific laws
relating to reckless driving that have
their own penalties and New Hampshire
does not require any person to have
insurance regardless of whether or not
they have a license
people who commit misdemeanors or
felonies by driving recklessly or under
the influence should be charged for
those infractions as appropriate
in terms of driving without a license
reverting a first offense back to a
citation and let me be clear any
additional offenses should definitely
have higher consequences as appropriate
but first offenses will help reduce the
burden on our overloaded court system
it'll allow an opportunity to educate
people who make inadvertent mistakes or
a single poor decision
and it will provide a penalty that
actually fits the violation
you to vote Yes and pass HP 201 FN to
have a penalty that fits the infraction
I do ask for a division vote and I ask
you all to push the green button when we
do remember you all the questions
no remember does not yield
the motion before us is on a pass on
House Bill 201 a division has been
requested members take your seats
the motion before us is the motion to
Auto pass in hospital 201 it's the
division goal jail recognized
representative Rhodes for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that New Hampshire is one of the
least restrictive states to operate a
vehicle and if I know by passing this
law would be an insult to every person
that has taken the necessary steps to
obtain and maintain a driver's license
and if I know that I can renew my
driver's license online without ever
leaving my house would I now press the
red button so another motion can be made
thank you Mr Speaker
jail recognized representative Perry
God's wife for parliamentary
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill lowers the
penalty for an unlicensed driver for the
first offense of driving without a
license from a Class B misdemeanor to a
violation
and if I know that getting a license and
insurance can be a financial issue for
young people in rural areas and an
impossibility in New Hampshire for the
undocumented workers
in Florida if I know that immigration
status can also be impacted by
conviction for Class B misdemeanor which
is the current penalty for driving
without ever having a license and that
some people in our state are caught
between a rock and a hard place when it
comes to the need to drive to get or
keep employment and the need to feed
their families and finally if I know
that nothing in this bill changes the
fact that first offenders will still be
penalized then when I press the green
button and support the art to pass
recommendation thank you Mr Speaker
motion before us is the motion to Auto
pass in House Bill 201 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you opposed or
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
thank you
under 90 voting a 180 165 voting a
committed report of Auto passes adopted
committee on criminal adjusting the
public safety to our children to
referred House Bill 581 FN act repealing
the controlled Drug Act and establishing
a committee to study the policy in
statutory changes necessary to implement
the repeal considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
than if Karen Reed for the committee
Geo recognizes representative senator
natasko
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker today we have the opportunity
to make an historic decision in the
fight against the failed War on Drugs
the bill before us proposes the complete
deletion of the controlled Drug Act in
the state of New Hampshire putting an
end to this outdated harmful policy once
and for all
the bill represents the end of the war
on drugs in New Hampshire and we have a
chance to make a real difference in the
lives of our citizens the controlled
Drug Act has been in place for decades
and what has it achieved we've seen
increased rates of incarceration
addiction and drug-related violence it's
time to acknowledge that this policy has
failed and move on to a more effective
approach
as we consider this bill it's important
to remember the lessons of History the
parallels between alcohol prohibition
and the war on drugs are striking both
policies were created with the best of
intentions but ultimately proved to be
ineffective and cause more harm than
good
during prohibition the government banned
production importation transportation
and sale of alcohol in the United States
this resulted in an increase in
organized crime black market sales and
the spread of dangerous substances all
while failing to reduce the consumption
of alcohol
similarly the War on Drugs have been
characterized by aggressive enforcement
mandatory minimum sentences and a focus
on punishment over treatment
this has led to a massive increase in
incarceration rates particularly for
non-violent drug offenses and has done
little to stem the tide of drug
addiction and abuse
instead create a black market for drugs
contribute to the spread of disease and
left countless families devastated by
the consequences of this misguided
policy
prohibition was a failed policy that
only increased violence and Corruption
and the same can be said about the War
on Drugs we have seen the devastation it
has caused
it may be argued that this decision is
too simple and the problem is more
nuanced than just ending the War on
Drugs uh but this bill will allow us to
redirect our resources towards more
effective drug policy such as prevention
education and treatment
uh moreover the public wants this change
polls show that 83 percent of Americans
want to end the war on drugs and so it's
time to listen to our constituents and
make this a reality
and we have the power to make a
difference in the lives of our citizens
in conclusion I urge all my fellow
legislative support this bill we have
had the chance we have the chance to
make history to end the War on Drugs in
New Hampshire
uh so let's not over complicate it with
endless hearings and meetings and take
action now to make a real difference
thank you Mr Speaker as a member yield
the questions
uh yeah I'll let you I yell the
questions
remember yields you may inquire
thank you Mr speaker thank you
representative for taking my question to
be really short here would you agree
that the main accomplishment of the War
on Drugs over the last 50 years is that
we now have drugs that are more
available more deadly and less expensive
than they were when we started this
ridiculous War
yes I agree and I would add that the War
on Drugs has actually increased the
potency of uh of drugs than they
otherwise would be thank you
chair recognize representative wheeler
thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to speak
against the committee report the War on
Drugs has failed the controlled Drug Act
has failed it has not stopped people
from using or abusing drugs it doesn't
keep drugs out of the hands of our
children or stop people from overdosing
it does criminalize working-class people
without the means to litigate this in
court it does leave people mistrusting
our law enforcement and other
institutions
we've heard these arguments against drug
laws and the drug war ad nauseam so I'd
like to just end with a quote from a man
who helped pass the controlled Drug Act
you know what this War on Drugs was
really about
the Nixon campaign in 1968 and the Nixon
white house after that had two enemies
the anti-war left and black people
you understand what I'm saying
we knew what we knew we couldn't make it
illegal to be either against the war or
black but by getting the public to
associate hippies with marijuana and
blacks with heroin and then
criminalizing both heavily we could
disrupt those communities raid their
homes break up their meetings and vilify
them night after night on the evening
news did we know we were lying about the
drugs of course we did so I think given
the intent of this law given that it was
so flawly it was passed with so many
flaws that it would be the least we can
do as a body to repeal Allah with such
intent thank you Mr Speaker
do you recognize your representative Roy
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I'm not
going to defend the War on Drugs I don't
even really know what that means it's so
complicated now but I just want to make
clear what what the representatives are
proposing they're proposing that we
today vote to legalize heroin legalize
cocaine legalize methamphetamines
legalize
um let me see what else LSD PCP you name
it they want to legalize it today and
they want you to vote for it because
they see your constituents want that
I checked my messages I didn't get any
messages you might get stitched through
and say could you please go to Concord
and make all drugs legal
finally I would say that while we've
been sitting here there's a darn good
chance that someone's died of an
overdose of fentanyl while we've been
sitting here in our warm room debating
this so I think that maybe if we we are
going to do this it's going to be
thoughtful it's going to be slow it's
going to be measured and it's got to be
careful thank you
the motion before us is the committee
report of inexped into legislate on
House Bill 581 FN genocena the testoster
roll call it is sufficiently seconded
members take your seats
foreign
this is going to be a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
wheeler for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the controlled Drug Act was
passed with ill intent and for political
purposes would I then press the red
button so another motion could be made
sure recognizes representative Roy for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that the
controlled drug DAC in Washington may
have been posed to that reason not in
New Hampshire and if I know that we need
to slow down and do this in a measured
way
I would vote to support the committee's
recommendation of an experience
legislative thank you
motion before us is in expedient to
legislate in house bill 581.
this is a roll call vote you're in favor
you'll press the green button of your
post you'll press the red button
boarding stations are open for 30
seconds
different
members president have an opportunity to
vote also attend the state of the vote
286 floating a 70 voting a committee
report is adopted
20 on criminal justice and Public Safety
to which was deferred House Bill 643 FNA
and act relative to legalizing marijuana
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is in expedient to
legislate then of Kevin Pratt for the
committee
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
don't suppose nay
the eyes have it committee report is
adopted
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 45 an act
establishing a committee to study
student loan forgiveness in New
Hampshire having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexped into
legislate it's in a Valerie McDonald for
the committee
thank you
representative San Andreas has asked for
a roll call it is sufficiently seconded
uh representative has requested a vote
also be in order
and it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote
the motion before us is inexpeding to
legislate on House Bill 45.
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed you'll
press the red button voting station
foreign
45 this is going to be a roll call vote
did I recognize the representative Ladd
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you
thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know the education committee
recognizes the importance and need to
address the issue of student debt as New
Hampshire college graduates have the
highest student debt in the country
and if I know this bill requests that a
committee be formed to study student
loan forgiveness but
if I also know that the legislature
already has a committee the public
higher education study committee that is
responsible for higher education
oversight and Associated issues such as
student debt would I then understand the
intent of this bill can be addressed
without the need for an another
committee by pressing the green button
the motion before us is in the committee
report of inexperiential legislative and
house bill 45. this is a roll call vote
here in favor you'll press the green
button of your opposed or press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
thank you
representative
I need to come up or down thank you
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
three
hundred and twelve voting a 43 voting a
committee report is adopted
thank you
committee reporters are not
radio and education to which was
referred House Bill 131 and act required
reports concerning school policies on
classroom recordings and in classroom
observers having considered the same
report the same following resolution
resolved that is in expedient to
legislate then of Rick lad for the
committee are you ready for the ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
it's bosnay
the eyes have it and the committed
report is adopted
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 540 FM local act
relative to adequate education grant
amounts for pupils receiving special
education services considered the same
report the same with the following
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Rick Ladd for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
the proposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted and it's on its way to
finance
majority of the committed an education
to which was referred
House Bill 601 FM local net relative to
State participation in the Medicaid
direct certification program for free
and reduced
price School meals have been considered
the same report the same with the
recommendations to fill out the pass in
a quick lad for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following Amendment recommendation at
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
thank you
everything
representative cordelli move's Amendment
zero four four h
inted in house Record 12 pages
56-57 are you ready for the question on
got a debate on the amendment
Jennifer chair recognized representative
cadelli
uh thank you Mr Speaker
this bill is for direct certification
and Medicaid it's really a resolution or
directive not real legislation as we
would think of it it directs the
Department of Health and Human Services
and education to seek participation of
federal pilot program to use Medicaid
enrollment family information and
confidential doe information on students
to register students in the free and
reduced lunch program
puts nothing in statute and that's part
of the problem
you will hear about the benefits of this
program and that it will automatically
register uh families it will probably
increase the number of students eligible
for free and reduced lunches and
probably more differentiated Aid to
school districts it's all probably true
there are already similar programs in
place for snap and TANF food stamps and
welfare recipients for direct
certification
neither of these programs is in statute
or in rules it evidently is just
agreements signed by departments with
federal agencies
that requires matching This Confidential
student information to register the
students
we are told that these processes have I
opt out ability for parents
and we're told the Medicaid will also
but opting out it's too easy to skip
over an opt-out question on an exam on a
registration
but we also had testimony that in the
stat snap and TANF opt-outs a couple of
years ago
those opt-outs were terminated someone
just decided to get rid of them and so
they're gone and so they're not in place
anymore
who knew
someone in an apartment made that
decision there was no legislative or
oversight to that decision
this amendment will do three things
it will put the Medicaid direct
certification program in statute
it will require parental opt-in
rather than opt out
and thirdly it will require
DHHS and doe Commissioners to certify
that the programs comply with all
federal and state laws
if we are going down this path there has
to be legislative oversight
this will put it into doe statutes right
in the Privacy section
parents opt in for so many programs we
just passed legislation about adopting
in for WIC program we opt in to run for
office parents should have that same
ability when when they enter into this
program in addition this amendment
specifies that when they opt in it will
list the confidential student
information that's being matched what
information from their student will be
used and that is the name date of birth
address and sex confidential information
from the state doe web excuse me
database
so this program this amendment makes
this an opt-in program we think that's
very important
finally does the process comply with
federal and state law we have very
strict
privacy laws about confidential student
information
in fact there was a federal program a
federal law related to data matching
does this program comply with those
laws
this amendment requires a certification
by the Commissioners that it does
if you vote against this amendment
you are really giving unlimited power to
a bureaucrat in one of our state
agencies
if you vote for this amendment you are
providing for oversight
protecting student privacy and voting
for parents
thank you and Mr Speaker I request a
division vote
should I recognize representative luno
thank you very much Mr Speaker I'm sorry
could you hold for a minute there's a
member yield to questions
yes member yields
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker and representative
for taking my question
you stated that the original bill was a
directive rather than legislation can
you please explain that
yes thank you for the question
um yes the basic bill as is in front of
us does not put anything in statute it's
basically two sentences
the Department of Education to seek
participation in the demonstration
projects to evaluate direct
certification with Medicaid administered
by the USDA the Department of Health and
Human Services shall assist the
Department of Education as needed in
pursuing and implementing this new
direct certification
that's it there's nothing about opt-in
there's nothing about privacy nothing
it's a cart launch for our departments
to work with the feds
chair recognize representative my
apology sir
no worries thank you very much Mr
Speaker and um and this is exactly what
the governor has asked us to do
um the proposed floor amendment was
never considered by the committee it
would essentially nullify every
Advantage stemming from the state's
participation in the Medicaid direct
certification pilot program these
advantages include an easy application
free process for students excuse me to
receive free and reduced price meals at
schools reduce time spent by Cool School
administrators chasing down paperwork
and more accurate data used to determine
school funding since 2012 39 other
states have joined the Medicaid direct
certification program which has resulted
in a 12 percent increase in the number
of students that now can receive a free
and reduced price meal at school in in
the state of Texas it's actually
increased School Meal participation by
48 percent
proponents of the amendment say that it
protects privacy but nothing could be
further than the truth
House Bill 601 as introduced without any
amendments is what we need it's what the
governor has asked for and it has strong
bipartisan support
House Bill 601 as introduced is good for
kids good for families and good for
taxpayers please vote no on the
amendment
Senator Fidelity has asked for a
division vote on the amendment members
take your seats
promotion before us is the Amendment
044h
this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative petronella for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that the Medicaid direct
program
has little to do with actually feeding
children and has more to do with
collecting data if I know that this
amendment puts the Medicaid direct
program and statute if I know that this
amendment will put give parents control
by opting in
if I know that this amendment will
require DHHS and the doe to certify
compliance with federal and state laws
and if I know that it limits the power
of unelected bureaucrats would I press
the green button
chair recognize representative for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you very much Mr Speaker if I know
that the amendment is bad for kids bad
for families and bad for taxpayers then
would I press the red button and vote no
on the proposed amendment thank you
the motion before us is amendment zero
four four four h
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposal press the
red button boarding stations are open
for 30 seconds
while members president an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
the vote
176 boning a 174 voting a the amendment
is adopted
we're now on the motion of ought to pass
as amended
chair
uh for what reason does a member rise
move to table house bill 601.
it is a it is a proper motion
motion before us as the table House Bill
601 division has been requested members
take your seats
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 601
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
of course
foreign
opportunity to vote also attend for the
state of the vote
161 voting a 195 voting a the motion to
table fails
now we're back to the question on auto
pass as amended
chair recognizes
son of Alicia Lucas
I have read the application on this bill
this bill does not say
we have an option it doesn't even say
that
um
the amendment that we just passed will
have any effect but it does say is that
if we apply just apply
we are making a contractual agreement
with the federal government to follow
through with this program and it also
says they can add whatever rules they
want
do you guys remember the 55 mile an hour
speed limit
do you guys remember how we collect our
Federal gas taxes and how they
supposedly give them back so we can take
care of our roads and yet
if we didn't put 55 miles we weren't
getting our money back to to take care
of our roads
and so the idea that we can say parents
opt in
I don't believe it I believe it's
whatever the federal government says
we're going to do and we better jump to
it or we're going to lose all of our
free or reduced lunch money and we won't
be able to support any children to get
free or reduced lunch
the other thing there
the complaint is that we're not getting
these this paperwork back well their
parents who are absolutely adamant
against filling out this paperwork
because they don't want the schools to
know that they're on Medicaid
they're embarrassed at having to be on
Medicaid and they don't want anybody to
know well guess what if we pass this
bill
every kid on free and reduced lunch is
going to be Medicaid and it's and a list
of those kids would be sent to the
school so we're going behind the parents
back in their desire for privacy
and giving the schools a list of the
kids who are on Medicaid
yet we have we
we instituted
a um
Constitutional Amendment valuing
people's privacy and yet we're going to
vote to go around parents backs
and then well
the forms fall off when you get to
particularly Juniors and seniors in high
school
even when their parents fill them out
the students don't turn them in hmm I
wonder why seems that that's about the
time kids can start working on their own
a lot of those kids either don't want
anybody else to know that they're free
and reduced lunch or they absolutely
hate the meals
I mean a lot of them say they're
disgusting
and they finally are able to get a
little of their own money and do a la
carte meals which they like a lot better
so why don't we stop going around the
backs of parents and students and
just if they want the meals they can
fill out the paperwork if they don't
they don't peel out the paperwork a lot
of this is actually about trying to get
greater numbers for free and reduced
lunch for figuring out how to give extra
money to schools there are other ways of
doing that we don't need to go behind
parents backs to do it so please vote
against passing this thank you very much
chair recognize representative Belcher
thank you Mr Speaker colleagues uh
you've just heard some very good reasons
why we shouldn't pass this bill I'll
just expand on that very briefly
um first of all as you've heard this is
a brand new federal program and federal
programs come with Federal mandates now
you may or may not know this
but Federal mandates as they currently
exist in education law are currently
overriding New Hampshire state law
we cannot do the things we want to from
curriculum to nutrition because they are
federally mandated that we adopt certain
guidelines in order to receive money
because of these Federal programs that
we keep getting into
I need people to understand that
anything we try to do to fix education
in the granite state
until we get the federal government out
is merely a Band-Aid on a bullet wound
we need to do better than that
with that I would ask you to vote
against the o2p OTP motion thank you
recognizer Representative Keith
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise today in support of House Bill
this is a very simple bill
it's simply allows
the division of Health and Human
Services
and the Department of Education to share
data
it will eliminate the need for school
districts you have to go through the
whole process of filling out forms for
free and reduced lunch
it will give us better more accurate
numbers when we are filling when we are
compiling the adequacy information so
that we'll have more accurate numbers
for free and reduced lunch students
going into the formula
this bill
is simple
it just directs the Department of
Education to work with Health and Human
Services
the information is already in existence
it just allows them to connect it all
information is kept completely
confidential
it also allows for more students we know
that a lot of families don't fill out
those forms and a lot of children don't
get access to bring reduced lunch meals
as they should and this would make that
difference
this is a good bill it's a simple Bill
we heard Governor sununu talk about its
importance to make this happen
we know that more hungry kids in schools
are kids that don't learn as well we
need this to happen it's a simple it's
not even going to happen right away it
wouldn't be enacted until
2026. so I ask for your support we have
talked about this bill time and time and
time again it's not nefarious in any
ways it's just a plain simple build that
connects two sets of existing data in
order to help children so I thank you
for your support and I hope you will
press the green button and vote Yes on
this Bill thank you very much
the motion before us has ought to pass
as amended on House Bill 601
a division has been called
expected somebody to uh so this will be
a division of vote members take your
seats
foreign
601 this is a division vote
yeah I recognize as representative Ladd
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that a number of high school
students in grades 10 11 and 12 these
students that are eligible for the
program are no longer participating due
to a number of issues within the schools
much different than the
number of kids to participate in the
Middle School grades if I know 39 states
are participating in the Medicaid direct
program without issues associated with
mishandling of student privacy and
family confidential information and most
importantly these high school students
in those states are having meals
nutritious meals
at lunch
and if I know HHS has stated that
medical or Medicaid information will not
be shared with de doe without parent
permission
and lastly
if I also know that Medicaid direct
program in this bill very is very
similar to the same process in which
school districts currently determine
meal program eligibility using snap and
TANF
would I therefore support the 13-7
committee report
and as amended recently this afternoon
by pressing the green button thank you
motion before us is the motion to Auto
pass as amended on House Bill 601 this
is a division vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your oppose will press a red
button quoting stations are open for 30
seconds
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
also attended to the state of the vote
205 voting yay 151 voting a committee
report is adopted and it's on its way to
finance
foreign
election law to which was referred house
bill 196.
establishing a commission to review and
make recommendations on campaign Finance
laws brought to us without
recommendation
um
representative reason does it member
rise
I would like to make a motion Mr Speaker
stage of motion uh and I would like to
speak to the motion of the motionist
table
there's no debate on tabling motion
can you do pis
yeah
okay
are we um
okay as for division I I okay
a division has been requested
and can we ask for pi
everybody okay
okay I'll do it
sorry for the confusion
hold on
thank you
the motion before us is the table
house bill 196.
you have requested a division
correct
division we've already got the question
before
so
if you would like to do a parliamentary
inquiry representative Wayne I recognize
you for parliamentary inquiry thank you
you
if I know that the chair and vice chair
of this committee and I have agreed that
we will set up a subcommittee as
requested in the bill
and if I know that the vice chair has
agreed
I'm sorry George
okay
then would I please vote to table this
bill
here recognizes to representative Berry
for parliamentary yes Mr Speaker if I
know that it's time to vote and that we
should press the green button when I now
press the green button
foreign
since the table house bill 196.
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button of
your opposal press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
thank you
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
the vote
339 voting yay seven voting a cabling
motion passes
thank you
okay
all right the host will be in order
majority of the committee on environment
and agriculture which was referred House
Bill 252 in act exempting agricultural
operations from certain Municipal noise
ordinances
have been considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment the
recommendation bill on a password
Amendment Barbara Quantum for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee have have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following Amendment the recommendation
Bill ought to pass with Amendment it's
an Allison Nabb for the minority of the
committee
the majority of the committee
amendment is zero one eight six h
the question is on the majority
committee report
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
Mr Paul's nay
the eyes have it the majority
committee amendment is adopted
we now have
an amendment by representative NAMM
which is zero four five three h
in the in the chair recognizes the chair
recognizes uh representative
thank you Mr Speaker I rise today to
speak in support of floor Amendment 453h
which would add a clause accepting
agritourism from this bill I come from a
town with a proud agricultural Heritage
in fact the largest farm in our town is
owned by the former Speaker of the House
The Honorable Doug scammon when we look
at this bill we think of those Farms
large and small that might need to work
at all hours of the day from pulling a
stuck cow out of pasture to unloading a
truck in the early hours
however the definition of farming and
state law is extremely expansive and can
include a homeowner with one or two
chickens or the eight raised beds I have
in my backyard
this legislation would exempt any person
involved in agriculture at any size or
level from local Norse ordinances the
definition of farming and state law also
includes marketing which in turn
includes agri-tourism this amendment
would create some guard rails to the
bill by adding an exception for
agri-tourism
this amendment was in fact suggested and
supported by the Commissioner of
Agriculture who otherwise supported the
bill commissioner Jasper expressed
concerned that including agritourism in
the exemption could in fact exacerbate
exasperate disagreements between farms
and town residents the commissioner also
believes decisions about noise ordinance
relative to agritourism businesses
should remain under local control
agritosa may include everything from
corn mazes to farm camps to pick your
own spots to Vineyards it can represent
a way for Farms to become more viable
and is supported in numerous ways in
state law it is important to note that
this amendment does not preclude a
municipality from exempting and
agritourism business from noise
ordinances it just allows our towns and
cities to continue to make decisions at
a local level instead of into one size
fits-all model for the entire State as a
representative said earlier today one
size fits all rarely fits anyone
a member of the environment and
agriculture committee asks why
agrotourism businesses shouldn't just be
allowed to do their business they should
this amendment just recognizes that
agricultural properties are often
adjacent to residentially zoned areas
and that town should have the ability to
consider applying noise ordinances to a
wedding venue at a farm property in the
same way they would to a restaurant's
event space
to continue to show support for our
state's Farmers while also ensuring a
positive relationship for agritourism
businesses within their towns and cities
Guided by local control I urge you to
vote ought to pass on this amendment and
I do request a division vote thank you
Mr Speaker
chair recognizes representative Contour
I oppose this amendment
this amendment allows agricultural
activities to be exempt from noise
ordinances except for agritourism
the real complaint was what if they host
weddings on the farm
but agritourism is so much more than
just weddings
it is education it is fundraises it's
Farm to Table dinners it's full moon
walks it's bonfires and so and more and
more and more how many weddings can one
Farm hold outdoors in our climate
if we think that officials can be
reasonable
let us ask the woman who is harassed
because her rooster crowed outside the
noise ordinance ours
or maybe take a page out of the Town who
went
to someone and asked if they could turn
down the music after a certain hour
do you want houses or do you want Farms
help the farmers keep their land and
press the red button thank you
the motion before us is the nav floor
Amendment zero four five
three h
it's in your seat pockets
the division has been requested members
take your seats there will be a division
vote on this amendment
foreign
thank you
order
floor Amendment zero four three five
three h do I recognize the
representative datsy for a parliamentary
inquiry
uh Mr Speaker
if I believe that Farms should be
Exempted from noise ordinances to main
their ability to operate as Farms but if
I also believe that agritourism is not
always related to farming would I now
press the green button to pass Amendment
0453h and give back to cities and towns
the right to regulate agrotourism under
their local noise ordinances
Geo recognized representative Creighton
for a parliamentary inquiry
speaker
farming is a 24 7
business
if I further know that farmers Seek many
different ways to earn or to earn income
and grow their business
and if I further know that this
amendment would hinder Fordham Farmers
freedom to operate would I then push the
red button to support New Hampshire
Farmers thank you very much Mr Speaker
motion before us is floor Amendment four
zero four five three h
this is a division vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your opposed will press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
foreign
six voting a
the now four Amendment fails now we're
on to Auto pass as amended the chair
recognizes representative germanov
thank you Mr Speaker I Rise this
afternoon to speak or this evening at
this point uh to speak in opposition to
House Bill 252 for three reasons uh
first of all as my honorable colleague
representative NAB pointed out earlier
our definition of agriculture are an
agricultural operation is very broad
this isn't necessarily just Farm
operations that we might have in mind it
might also apply to activities that are
being carried out in more residential
kind of of neighborhoods uh and that
leads me to my second point is different
localities in our state have different
demographics and they have different
geographies and they should be allowed
to make these decisions based upon what
is right for them
and finally
if we pass this as a state law
and a municipality or two come back to
us in the next year the year after that
we'll say to them we're not going to
change state law just because one town
or one municipality
doesn't think that this is working for
them if a municipality passes noise
ordinance at the local level and it
doesn't work out very well next year
they can go back and change it or they
can tweak it they can do what is right
for them
finally Mr Speaker
many of my honorable friends in the
house use a couple of phrases
that confuse me at times one is local
government and the other is that we
shouldn't
try to come up with solution one size
fits all solutions I'm confused about
what we mean by local government because
sometimes from what some of my honorable
friends
argue in this well that seems to mean
that localities should be allowed to
make these decisions for themselves and
other times as in this bill it seems to
mean that we in Concord are going to
make those decisions for them
likewise with reference to the idea that
a one size fits-all solution is not the
right solution it's not the New
Hampshire way this is a
one-size-fits-all solution
our towns our localities have specific
demographics they have specific
geography they have specific interests
and needs in cultures and I think it's
the New Hampshire way to let them make
these decisions for themselves thank you
very much Mr Speaker and I ask for a
division vote
chair recognizes represent Contour
thank you Mr Speaker and honorable
colleagues we just heard a lot
but let me tell you farms in New
Hampshire have been around for since the
beginning of New Hampshire
they Supply our food we go to them for
local food
we have more more and more people moving
into our state that don't understand
how farming is crucial
to us in our rural character
if we don't give Farmers an option
to make ends meet
are six percent food security that we
can now Supply six percent of our
population with local food will diminish
and if you think six percent is good
I beg you to take a look around
and other states
we need to support the local farmers no
matter how we can
and like I said we have a lot of people
moving into our towns that do not
understand
the role character and
how farming is a 24 7
365 day a week job
it's not a nine to five job it's not a
four to ten job it's 24 7. and it
doesn't matter what the weather is I
urge you to pass this thank you
foreign 252.
sin of Santa natasto has requested a
roll call when it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
members take your seats
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of ought to pass it
amended and house bill 252.
this is a roll call vote care recognizes
represent whoa
very parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker uh honorable
members of the House
Mr Speaker if I know that HB 252 places
the determination in an acting of noise
ordinance surrounding our farms and
agritourism solely on our state
legislature therefore making it more
difficult for local municipalities to be
proactive if changes need to be made to
reflect Community concerns and assist
our Farmers with these complaints and if
I further know Mr Speaker that it has
always been best practice to allow our
farmers and agritourism to speak
directly to their municipality
surrounding noise when these rare
complaints or concerns arise
would I then vote no on the otpa and
select the red button for a further
motion can be made thank you
chair recognize representative Creighton
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker colleague
if I know that it's hard New Hampshire
is a rural state
if I also know that the soul of New
Hampshire is informing
then I would would I not push the green
button to allow Farmers the ability to
maximize their potential thank you Mr
Speaker
motion before this majority committee
report of autopasset has amended on
House Bill 252. this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposal press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
foreign
members president had an opportunity to
vote
I also attend to the state of the vote
266 148 184 voting a committee report is
adopted
chair recognizes the member from Auburn
representative Osborne for a third
reading motion
thank you resolved that the house now
adjourned from the early session that
the business of the late session be in
order at the present time that the
reading of bills be by title only in
resolutions by caption only then all
bills ordered a third reading be read a
third time by this resolution and that
all titles of bills be the same as
adopted and that they'd be passed at the
present time and when the house adjourns
today it be to meet Thursday February
23rd at 11 A.M
are you ready for the question on the
third reading motion I all those in
favor say aye
Elizabeth
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
we have the house will be in order
we have a few announcements and we have
some unanimous consents
Joe recognizes representative Ladd
thank you very much Mr Speaker
in addition to the scheduled 5 hearing
scheduled for the education committee
this coming Friday on the 24th at 9 30.
we will be executing the following bills
which are not in the calendar that's why
I'm announcing them to you now HB 170
HB 394
HB 563
hb632
hb651 and
hb654 at the conclusion on Friday we
have finished our 93 hearings that we
had to conduct
do you recognize representative Osborne
thank you Republicans will still caucus
at nine o'clock tomorrow morning this is
optional uh feel free to sleep in if you
like
care recognize representative Wilhelm
uh the Democrats will caucus at 10 30.
in the cafeteria and our special guests
will be there at that time as well
thanks
chair recognizes representative Panic
for a unanimous consent
chair recognizes representative C league
for the anonymous consent
thank you Mr chair and thank all of you
I know there are some people coming up
to just stand with me
um
ask for your attention as we discussed
yesterday in the wee hours of the
morning someone or some group committed
a series of hate crimes in the city of
Portsmouth with more than 14 businesses
plus my synagogue plus some homes and
private property spray painted with
hateful symbols
I come work for you today as many of
these other people are joining me to ask
everyone to condemn these hate crimes
and as there are indications that some
of these hate groups have additional
plans for additional acts of hatred over
this weekend
I ask us not only to condemn those acts
but to speak out against hate and to
call out all those who perpetrate hate
and perpetrate these acts thank you
Mr Speaker may I request that these past
remarks be added to the permanent record
without without objection
chair recognize herbs
here I recognize you representative
Paris Hall
parcel
let's go
yes the Russian uh the Russian
aggression against Ukraine happened
approximately one year ago
and I think it would be a proper thing
to just stop and pause the second you
consider the crimes against humanity
that have been perpetrated Again by this
aggression
thank you
representative Osborne loose at the
highest standard recess for the purpose
of the introduction of bills and role
build amendments Road Grove reports and
receiving messages are you ready for the
question all those in favorites say aye
Mr postnay the eyes have it
houses and recess until tomorrow morning
at 11 o'clock